this is Jocko podcast number 181 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening
get him out we were in Cambodia alone
with no fixed-wing aircraft
Sal's eyes were as big as saucers I told
Bubba to give me a claymore mine with a
five-second fuse
I gave Bubba and [ __ ] the move quick
signal as we move back to the LZ I
stayed at the rear of the formation with
Sal and hastily with sow hastily
covering our tracks we had only gone a
short distance when Sal hissed beaucoup
VC beaucoup VC I could see the pith
helmets in the distance coming from the
south
i radioed the Green Hornet's CNC
helicopter and told them to the return
with their gunships and to pick us up at
the primary LZ ASAP CNC said they'd have
assets on site in ten minutes or less
now even ten minutes seemed like a long
time Tuan and I fired our m79 as two
high bursts which slowed the NVA down
for a few seconds sau opened fire
shooting shingle single shots and moving
backwards no longer bothering to cover
our tracks I yelled to Bubba to move out
at double-time the race for life was on
sau sau hissed a hip and pointed north
damn
there were pith helmets and NVA uniforms
coming at us from the north - and at a
dead run sound I placed a claymore
behind a tree pulled the fuse lighter
and ran the NVA were now running and
shooting wildly we sprinted to catch up
to the team as the Claymore exploded
the NVA kept on charging South quickly
placed his claim more in front of a tree
and ran while Tuan and I provided
covering fire we sprinted toward our
team as the second Claymore detonated we
felt the blast on our backs as we ran as
[ __ ] and Bubba pushed toward the LZ hip
Tuan sau and I fired
back using the immediate action drills
the entire team had practiced for hours
on end Tuan's m79 rounds were deadly
effective those combined with my m79
rounds and the car 15 fire from hip and
sau temporarily starred stalled the hard
charging NVA troops we reach the LZ
quickly in comparison to how cautiously
we had exited it as the team set up a
hasty perimeter hip replaced another
claymore in the path of the NVA that
were charging us from the south to the
north bubba rigged a claymore with a
contact detonator on a tripwire as the
tide of pith helmets flowed toward us
Bubba and I opened fire with our m79 s
and sau and hip opened up on full auto
with their car 15s more NVA emerged from
the smoke of the m79 high-explosive
rounds and tripped Bubba's claymore
that's when the first Green Hornet
gunship arrived I popped a smoke
canister and directed a gun run to the
west of our perimeter within seconds the
gunship roar gunship roared in front of
our perimeter shredding the NVA ranks
slowing them down for a few seconds the
Green Hornet's firepower was incredible
finally the Green Hornet slick that
inserted us into the target area arrived
on the LZ as close to our position as
possible with his left door facing us
the nose pointing north or northwest
fortunately the air force had made it to
us in less than 10 minutes
the relentless NVA kept coming after us
as Tuan and I each Unleashed one more
m79 high-explosive round at the NVA
bubba led the team toward the air force
Huey we always had an American lead the
team's approach to an American
helicopter to avoid any confusion in
regard to South Vietnamese team members
on st idaho i fired the last claymore as
the wave of NVA troops got in front of
it the last claymore blast gave me a few
precious seconds to make it to the Huey
and that right there is another glimpse
into the insanity that John striker
Meyer known as tilt lived through as a
Special Forces soldier in Vietnam a
recon team leader for Mack V SOG studies
an observation group command and control
and if you have not listened to podcast
180 yet then go listen to it tilt was on
that podcast and as human as he walked
out of the studio I knew that I needed
him to come back as quickly as possible
and I asked him and he graciously agreed
and here he is once again John Stryker
Meyer tilt good evening sir
good evening yeah you know you kind of
mentioned that that one operation right
there when you were out there facing
three divisions after you got fat dumb
and happy on Thanksgiving Day with a big
meal then you guys rolled out into the
field right indeed they've been and then
so how did that how did that operation
go now you guys got inserted how did you
end up in that situation where you're
running away putting 5 second fused
claymores facing the enemy what was how
what led up to that well we had a
briefing the night before and they were
hyper concerned because the three NVA
divisions 30,000 men were mi a lily and
the CIA dia whoever else is out there
had lost contact so that night myself
and the CEO and s3 went over the maps
Lia's reports all the Intel reports we
were up until after midnight so they
they came to you and said hey we're
missing 30,000 men any divisions of NVA
the first the third and the CIA loved in
we've got the DIA we've got spy planes
and all that stuff we can't find him so
then they come to you yeah okay and
you're like cool we got this oh yeah and
at the time I was still a spec for an e4
so and I hadn't met the CEO yet so the
first thing was he looks at me says
you're an e4
89 Billa what WTF I go look sir
long story short I said look I've run a
bunch of missions up north we're here
TDY how can I help you and he settled
down we looked then we were up all night
looking at those Intel reports and then
they also had pictures that were from
70,000 feet we'd never seen anything
like them my mom was the piano teacher
and one of her students dad worked on
lenses for aircraft to shoot from 70,000
feet he talked to me about him as a
young kid I go that's really cool well
now I knew what he was working on and
why he couldn't really talk about it
much but they that was the first time
the sr-71 we used overflights got it I
mean and I said where the hell these
come from because like this is mind body
and used to seeing no little pictures
close by people smile but for 70,000
feet we had a good estimate as to where
they might be and they said we can't
tell you this Dutch shut up you haven't
seen it and so we put it all together
just try this area I mean when in really
on the ground sure while maybe an hour
or so and then all hell broke loose and
did you didn't you you stumbled upon
their camp or like a camp that they had
recently left yeah well they have they
would have waystations a long way and so
we walked into him before we found
something but never what fires burning
the one still had a pot on it and so and
when we got back sound of guys estimated
then one division had just left and
their point dirt element was what came
back at us and the other from the north
was just moving into the base camp Oh
little sandwich yeah
little NVA sandwich there we go we were
- we were two below your basic baloney
yeah
hey did you go into that one real heavy
in terms of you is that because I if I
remember correctly from the book how
common was it that you carried the five
second fuses on the claymores we started
doing that a month earlier earlier part
of November I mean because we had a
couple targets where the numbers was
just incredible when they came out so I
always wanted to have
just in case so here we took a few extra
fuses you know John had his fuses and
Sal and [ __ ] they all knew how to work
those and so here I said because we saw
how open the area was we were used at
Triple Canopy up north so now we're in
Cambodia you could see three or four
hundred yards away maybe five hundred
yards
WTF times two and then you see the fifth
almost run match it's like whoa how does
it feel when you see the NVA in an open
run towards your position port arms
yeah good lord that was it was an
experience y'all take it to the grave
with me that's a nightmare
you're worse one how did you did you did
you in a situation like that you're
you're you've got I mean thousands of
potentially thousands of enemy soldiers
some of them are booths blatantly
running towards your position what are
you thinking in the back your mind are
you thinking hey we're not gonna get out
of this or you just I know for me in my
experiences which are nothing come close
to that but I was always just think
about getting my job done like ok this
is well this the best thing I could do
right now hey we need to put some people
over here let's get some machine gunners
up on the roof I would never get to a
point where I was or maybe I didn't have
enough time or I wasn't smart enough to
think about what big consequences were
coming but when you see when you see
those helmets running towards you at
poor garms you got to be thinking this
isn't looking real good for this isn't
looking real good for a boy no I I had
my first chocolate moment which was the
good news is we found these [ __ ] the
bad news is they're coming to kill my
ass Lily it's like well I'm glad we did
our homework last night this really
worked out well maybe a little bit too
well yeah and just thank God for the
Green Hornet's math they didn't get back
there it's just only a question of time
and they could you would you would keep
them on station Jennifer generally like
for like 10 or 15 minutes well this is
cambodia everything was different there
first we had no no fixed wings all we
had was the helicopters but there were
two greenhorns Air Force at that state
at that point in time November 68 they
were they had stated
are huge they were the fastest they
could carry more loads and their many
guns I think they had mounted many cuts
that they could handle manually some of
the early ones we saw were mounted and
so the helicopters would have limited
maneuverability but the one the year the
Air Force was just really on top of the
game well that's what came in and when
they came in with their minigun runs I
really bought us a couple of valuable
seconds seconds they were coming and you
can see him it's just like and I was
looking at some pictures of you
yesterday and you guys still had 20
round mags oh yeah
which you went which you'd load out to
18 rounds because you don't want to
compress the spring too much and cause a
jam right and we would have run over
your mother to get one of those 30 mile
jobs oh yeah
it was it was different so we always had
at least 600 plus rounds all in the
magazines did a couple extra bandoliers
just in case and you guys did make it
out that time obviously well yeah and
then you know here - when we left the
chopper pulls out and as we're lifting
off the NVA come out of the jungle the
thin jungle and was muddy had it rained
a day before and these guys are coming
out there they're at port arms and
they're trying to stop and the mud comes
up from their boots as they're trying to
stop come down to port arms
so me and a door gunner just and I
forget it force our [ __ ] we're just
getting these guys and they just stopped
like a cartoon and they go back this is
what happened just blew these guys back
in the mud from their boots was going up
into the props as they're trying to stop
and they're hit him and they just go
back into the jungle and we got the hell
out of there he strikes me as strange
because as I keep reading about the NVA
well I mean we know that these you know
this is an insurgency these guys are
looking to not fight when they don't
have to right that's why it always
surprises me in your in your stories how
determined they were like those guys hey
look ok the Americans they're getting on
the helicopter we'll let them go
whatever we'll come back next time you
know we don't want to die
right today because we don't have to we
can wait we can wait ten years we can
wait twenty years you know we go we're
gonna be here forever for them to have
that kind of determination where they
were just common in common and comments
and like you said on the last podcast
literally stacking up bodies so they
could get to you that would have been
just a crown jewel to capture a little
little Special Forces team oh yeah I
mean I they had to kill American award
so if they if they confirmed that they
killed one of us or got the body of a
dead body they would get their killed an
American award and they would get a
bonus of some sort maybe world heroes up
north for the rest of their lives
awesome
okay so that book and we talked about on
the last pot last podcast and I said it
last time and we we touched less than
10% of the book the stories are
completely insane and you can get that
book on Amazon you won't but you've
written that's not the only book you've
written you've written another one
another book is called on the ground and
this book again you're it's it's just
the same level of insanity you feel
strange for me to be sitting here
talking to you because every time I read
us through one of your stories I'm like
how's this guy making it out of this
there's you kick this one off with an
interesting story these guys one of the
it's you're not with them but it's a
recon team on the ground
a guy named Watkins is in charge Pat
Watkins and they're set up on a road and
they're doing a recon and I think they
set up an ambush to like an ambush to
take out some troops but they end up
with this massive NVA convoy and when I
say massive I mean massive it takes
hours to get by and there's people and
there's trucks and there's bulldozers
and there's tanks yeah and again I got
to point this out so we're probably
talking you know a thousand enemy
soldiers at least that are patrolling by
you for now for three hours they're
walking by you and meanwhile you've got
a team of six guys eight guys something
like it was seven or eight I forget but
yeah and they're under montanus and Pat
was familiar with all the Russian tanks
so he knew what the Russian tanks word
he had it all the Intel together
and just one of those another night and
saag another night in socks so they're
sitting there waiting and they
eventually they go by and and eventually
now one of the one of the ended soldiers
that was working alongside walkins one
of the members of the team was named
wrong ro ng and he comes up after this
convoy goes by and he comes up and this
this is what happens I'm going to the
book here wrong said he'd been watching
the road traffic just like Watkins and
it had been taken taken had been taken
as taken with it as he was I mean he was
like lost and like oh my god I can't
believe all your stuff while he was
staring at all the vehicles passing by a
hand had reached out and given his armor
shake a Mountain yard soldier one of
those the NVA had pressed into unwilling
service said it's your time for guard
duty is that close to the enemy or what
that's nuts
oh yeah completely nuts the mountain
yards which you guys called yards the
nuns the South Vietnamese even sometimes
former NVA soldiers what was it like who
did you mainly work with what were the
differences between the different groups
they're different ethnic personalities
and I know we didn't talk about a last
time you talked about in the book but
those those different ethnicities didn't
always get along well now especially
when it came to playing poker apparently
oh yeah cuz I first like the first few
days at Phu Bai they had a poker game
that went awry and and the Cambodian
lost he goes to his room gets a frag
grenade comes back and dumps it on the
Monty yards so we had an instant fire
flight into compound and you know you is
going through the training turn about
the different groups well that case we
had the Cambodians Montini Aras nuns and
a my team was South Vietnamese which
included at least four guys that came
south and 54 when there was an 18-month
truce where anybody the north could go
south when thousands did the Navy had a
special operation what has ships going
up to Noi and shipping thousands of
people south nobody went north nobody
wanted to be up with the commies mm-hmm
but we had those had
for the mom I team they were just
outstanding troops and so that was Phu
Bai and his team was that Bru which was
the lowest of the Amonte our tribes cute
they couldn't throw a hand grenade where
the shed but the fearless and they hate
they hated the North Vietnamese that's
that's one of the key points and you
talk about in the book is how much you
know what what the North Vietnamese had
done to the mount yards and how much
they fiercely hated them and how
fiercely loyal they were to you guys oh
yeah mazie troops and they would just
fight to the end
and as Morden there's more than one guy
who like a-10 who had we called him
affectionately our little people mm-hmm
the little people said I'll take a
bullet for you
that's how dedicated they were and they
proved that over and over again over and
over again
now some teams had troubles but we never
had it like a my team or with the
defenseman most majority teams the
little people took care of vetting their
own
so like when Idaho was wiped out Sal and
HAP went out and recruited and they were
young kids 15 years old we brought on
the team but they vetted him and we
never worried about him so we didn't
have to worry about the friendly fire or
what they call today with a blue fire
yeah they call it they call it friendly
fire yeah this is this close they have
another they have another word for it
too
I can't think of what it is because
friendly fire is like a mistake right
right what we're talking about is when
you know one of your own yeah one of
your Taliban forces or one of your your
local forces is actually a Taliban
person in turns on yours actually a
Mahdi militia guy turns on use of those
things those things are scary very
because he build up trust and all of a
sudden a guy turns on you yeah because
early on some of our eight camps had
trouble with that with their the mantra
that turned who had been more loyal to
the calmness for some reason but then
there's others had issues because they
they like Special Forces but they were
pissed off working with the South
Vietnamese and they they were just they
don't kill they would have to kill South
Vietnamese our allies or to
he's up north and sometimes you had like
guys don't don't kill our allies if not
today please yeah but I've never had
that my team was all South Vietnamese
man so one of the one of the other crazy
parts of of this book that you open with
or you start one of the early chapters
is this this attack on fo b4 which was
just sound completely completely
horrible and here's a quote from the
book the entire compound this is after
this attack happens the entire compound
was now a swirling battleground with
dozens of small but ready deadly dire
firefights in progress it was difficult
to tell the scantily-clad Americans and
indigenous personnel from the enemy and
there was no command coordination just a
lot of individuals struggling against
uncertain overwhelming odds the air was
filled with enough chaos to overload the
senses screams shouts bullets dust smoke
the smell of cordite burning wood rubber
and fuel and lastly the smell of seared
flesh and this this attack resulted in
17 Special Forces soldiers were killed
and I I don't know the number of
indigenous forces that were killed but
this sounded like just a complete I mean
it obviously was a big win for the enemy
and what was your perspective on all
that where were you when that happened I
was safely ensconced in fo b1 because fo
before had opened at the end of 67 and
event at the base of a mountain and
there's a whole lot of political reasons
why they're at the base of a mountain
but anyways they're there they had a
test attack body via Kong grant around
Christmas time of 67 and on August 23rd
after the dust settled the men who were
there like Pat Watkins estimated that
that test attack in December was a test
to see what could they had minimal
defenses up minimum wire the Internal
Security Force was riddled with Viacom
and they planned this attack for over a
year the sapper attack with the NVA
purrs as well as Vietcong highly trained
sappers and the conventional troops that
went in just for an annoying cloth and
carrying a weapon or a satchel charge
and hand grenades and so I was a food
buy they hit after midnight there's
always discussing about what time they
hit and since then we've had a military
intelligence officer came back and one
of the people that we said was 17 SS
he's 16 but still the highest number of
Green Berets killed in one battle in our
Special Forces history and fortunately
we had a recon team up on a hill on
Marble Mountain and I took out the the
mortars could the enemy were just
dropping mortars off the mountain into a
camp on top of everything else because
they don't care about friendly fire
speaking of friendly fire the enemy
doesn't care no they don't care if
they're dropping mortars on their own
people as long as they're killing some
of their enemy as well and some of them
had their bandanas and said we came here
to die and they did what did that with
the repercussions that went through your
community after that happened everybody
you know you it's one thing to talk
about being hit by an enemy force at
night they fight when they want to fight
that's a classic example of them doing
it they planned it for over a year they
even came in and took over the
indigenous mess hall for final briefing
in the base that night before they lost
the attack and so that's how
well-planned it was so they went in to
the indigenous camp the friendly camp
and gave their final briefing for the
attack inside of the friendly camp yep
and they had two of our loyal indigenous
troops that saw something suspicious
when he went up the NVA killed him right
away and left their bodies liner and so
it was really well-planned they knew to
camp we had a promotion board so all of
the at that time there was 6f Obi's one
through six this was fo before in Danang
and so all the people up for promotion
came in that day most of them stayed
that night on top of that we had they
had monthly command and control
briefings so every CEO as well as his s3
or the XO from each of the fo B's was
all at fo before and then the we had a
command and control element that was
based at the Danang airbase and they had
just moved on to base
so had increased population and they
knew it and that's the way they planned
and they planned that on a night when
there's no moon got to always respect
your enemy always and then we always
carried a weapon no matter where we went
there's one thing to be like F would be
one we had a good security there but
even then you don't know because they
vehicon would come and we found mortar
markers on the roof of the clubhouse and
they come in and walked it out there's
part of their vehicon would come in and
help do whatever was in base but they
were also there marking targets for
future mortar attacks on our compound
yeah that would happen at my first
deployment to Iraq I was in Baghdad and
we would they would occasionally roll up
guys that had their gps's
you know the little contractors guys
that did everything from empty out the
porta-potties there was guys that cut
hair these were just you know there was
civilians Iraqi civilians that worked on
the base and occasionally they'd get
rolled up they'd look at their phone or
look at their what are they carrying
they'd have a GPS with them and sure
enough they're out there trying to
figure out where you went where is a
good place to draw from order I actually
like kicked all the contractors out of
our compound completely and that's
something that I had heard from the
Vietnam vets was like nope you don't you
don't know who's who you just don't let
him in yeah so when I showed up we
actually moved the porta-potties outside
of our content we had to go outside if
we want to you they were still in
Americans area but they were not inside
of our compound so they so there was no
locals inside our compound at all zero
that's what we that's what we did when I
showed up and that's why I did it
because I was I had heard hey look
there's gonna be people that will be
gathering intelligence on you if they're
in the
compound you can't you can't vet every
single civilian that's gonna come out
there
the contractors scary it is yeah I was
that that is a the chapter that you
actually cover in two chapters because
it's such a horrible incident but that's
incredible read to see what those guys
went through oh yeah
how many did you just go in review
people how did you get all that
information well several of our guys
mouth will be one were there that night
so on the 24th after by noontime
everything is settled down they had you
know they have failed in their attack we
had control to Camp relief for us from F
will be one went down led by Colonel bar
Lieutenant Colonel bar and they went
through and cleaned up any of the left
pot last pockets of enemy soldiers and
there was a peel W camp right next to us
and Knisley
there was an effort to free that 500 so
POWs that we're gonna break news to come
in to further help overrun our base but
a couple of people made the key effort
along that line to the north to stop the
the pending escape of the NVA there
don't him in a tipping point oh yeah
erection there's a bit as good as a good
one to miss so anyways I answer your
question we had a lot of things in my
mind and then we closed that would be
one in January went south so shovel the
guys that had performed that night or
survived that we're all there so I
talked to him it's had mental notes and
then when I worked on the book we came
back and I did a piece for soldier
fortunate I usually
wrote under a nom de plume and we did a
first story written about that back in a
day and the soldier fortune print and I
have back in the eighties sometime or
early 90s so I used that and then build
on it and then John Peters the co-author
on that book on the ground he was there
at night and he was in the hooch he and
Doug got Shaw SF were too drunk from
that night like many of the people that
were there and but the young bill brick
charged out of hooch
gunned down immediately because they had
machine gun positions set up so anybody
came out they would gun them down and
that one element that was up on top of
the mountain there yeah and there was
there was one American with multiple is
that right there was one of those two Ed
Ames was up there he was the one zero
and the Larry Trimble was actually the
one doing a lot of the operational stuff
because Ames was monitoring the radio
and there was he Larry and his people
that took out the mortars that night or
the castor baby would have been much
higher and then there ended just said
hey we're going back down the next day
the next day Eddings went out the King
became and lifted him out they put it in
replacement who sprained his ankle or
something getting off two helicopters he
could not move but he so he worked the
rate of Al I was the guy taking care of
everything on top and yeah so the indid
said they wanted to go down that day and
I said well you may run into ambushes
going down Marble Mountain because what
we didn't know was underneath Marble
Mountain there was layers of of stories
they had hospitals down there Vietcong
training grounds everything else which
we learned about years later right along
with the Buddhist monks they were all
down there they coexisted peacefully and
so yeah they went down and Larry's for
awhile was by herself up there yeah they
got to I agree yeah those guys get a
firefight they come back yeah but when
they left
he's up there by himself he's just hey I
got this and he's the Lone Ranger own
Ranger gonna defend this thing until
he's dead that was his attitude that was
that's Larry freaking unbelievable tell
yeah absolutely you got to get this book
and read these these parts they're
they're epic epic heroism I mean and
crazy and incredible lessons learned as
well and I know you're now we're just
talking about lessons learned how easily
lessons get forgotten in the military it
happens in any organization but in the
military for sure you know because guys
are going there at a command for two or
three years or maybe for years and then
they're somewhere else and then someone
else comes in and different experiences
and no one agrees and what's right and
what's wrong and next thing you know you
the lessons are gone you forget them so
these books aren't here capture some
incredibly important lessons for anyone
on the battlefield or even close to it I
want to get down to kind of the end of
your first tour here and I'm going to
the book when I win one April 1969
arrived I was a conflicted man the end
of my tour was slated for 27 April so
far I had avoided the short-timers
attitude because after all it was
Vietnam and we were engaged in guerrilla
warfare across the fence nonetheless I
couldn't believe I was still alive I
looked forward to going back to the
world and yet I felt incredibly guilty
about leaving sow hep and [ __ ] and the
other men at CCN behind which is CCN is
what they renamed ff14 I believed in the
SF mission but how long could RT Idaho
go on without a casualty we hadn't lost
a man to hostile fire since May 1968
when the previous incarnation lost six
men in Laos RT Idaho had run a lot of
missions been in a lot of firefights it
wasn't a stay behind team that schemed
to remain in camp I was alive thanks in
large part to the skills and courage of
Hsiao hip Tuan and the other Vietnamese
team members as well as to the courage
and flying skills of the Vietnamese king
bee pilots and the American pilots the
Marines and Scarface the judge in the
executioner as well as tak air pilots
who always responded to our calls for
help we were alive because the Recon
gods had smiled on the reassembled RT
Idaho somehow the magic elixir of trust
training instinct guts timing and God's
good grace had fallen into place there
were other things that were collectively
wearing on me toward the end of my first
tour of duty by April 1969 both Lin
black and I were frustrated with having
enemy soldiers shooting us out of so
many targets as the helicopters
approached LZ s for landing
and when we weren't in the field we
found Artie Idaho getting frequently
assigned to guard duty atop Marble
Mountain because black and I had
continually butted heads with the reps
to add insult to injury they're
conveniently were never any choppers
available to airlift us to the top
we had to hump all of our supplies
ourselves which was still a dicey
business in the light of all the VC
activity in the village to the south of
the mountain and then in the caves deep
inside it we always moved up marble
mountain on full alert one on one such
trip Sal was training hyung to run point
hyung earned his pay that day as he
found and deactivated more than a dozen
booby traps including a claymore mine
that had a pressure released firing
device on it so you're sort of downtime
like hey we're back in camp we're just
gonna pull a little easy Duty here just
stand some guard duty oh we got to go up
to Marble Mountain oh there's no one to
take us up there so we're gonna have to
patrol up there and you're going up
there and you find on your way up there
more than a dozen booby traps oh yeah
that's trying to get to your guard duty
yeah I guess that could wear on you a
little bit that would that was a
significant day we didn't sleep well
that night and so this marble mountain
how long was the Patrol to get there
from base well it's close by and we
would usually walk around to the south
side of the mountain and there were
stairs that you go up before you get to
the trails because it was so steep to
get to the top that there's only a
certain number of ways you could walk up
mm-hmm and we you know you always try to
alter how you go but there's only so
many times you can alter it and so that
data way we went so Sal and hyung really
earned their pay I mean he and they fell
all these damn things but that'd been me
now Linds Lyn was a little bit more
sharp in keen-eyed to me but that'd be
me I would have been hamburger meat on
our first Claymore
and so that stuff I like I said it's
wearing on you obviously would wear on
anyone but that's the end of your tour
you get done with that tour and we
touched on this a little bit on the last
time but I wanted to go a little bit
deeper on it you you're coming back to
America after your first tour in Vietnam
how old do you say 69 23 23 years old
and when you get back again you touched
on this a little bit but they assign you
they assign you to like a signal a
signal company meaning you're not an
operational guy and you're in with some
and you're just coming out of Vietnam
and you're you're hearing people are
saying like hey what do you you know was
it even wasn't even there's guys that
are of actively avoiding vigo in Vietnam
oh yeah this is the 10th Special Forces
Group and they've been in Germany since
52 and they had they were actively
involved in a cold war and those guys
earned their pay there in fact one of
the first books just came out on dead a
which was there in a cold war but this
is a special forces unit so companies a
through D were active II because of my
MOS comma Oh cuz you're a radio man I've
to read a man they stuck me there and we
had four or five per tuned's and there
are new officers there butter bars like
right out of OCS they're young and they
treated everybody like was basic
training and my first thing was excuse
me this is an SM unit even though it's
signal so we had the signal the officers
inside that platoon they're not they're
not SF guys there are like
communications officers you know what
I'm not even sure eyes know they're
young and dumb and not respected and
then we had the two other for two starts
each one was fat and out of shape and
had avoided going to Vietnam and was
proud of it and made fun of me and a
couple of guys from D company because we
weren't smart enough to figure how to
get out of going numb I'm going like
wait a minute what are you wearing on
your head
and so we had some difficult moments
dealing with those guys and am i and so
we had routine training it's a little
company with trucks and all this stuff
to go and do these things I said
whenever we do one of these little
practice runs for a weekend or a mission
we will win because we're gonna get out
of here and let everybody else do the KP
and stuff and that just pissed everybody
off autumn or I pushed our young guys
and pushed them hard and bass could we
you know they do these training missions
you're out there three or four days all
is just calm oh mm-hmm and but the way
we did it
III can't even tell you the details now
because I just hated it but we won we
were the first ones back to the base we
had the most signal contact all the
criterion we met and we beat the fat
ramps now and and so you're back where
where were you stationed at that Fort
Devens Massachusetts so then you got it
I mean as some people that weren't ever
in the military don't realize this but
even when you're in the military when
you're back in America you go and
interact with normal civilian you know
you go to restaurants you go to bars you
live a normal life except for your job
you know whatever the hours you got to
work your job then you're living how was
that transition like now you're just
going out for a pizza on a Thursday
night now you're going out to have some
beers on a Friday night or Saturday
night how was that transition it was
difficult because actually we didn't
transition basically I hung out mostly
with the SF guys up there because this
Massachusetts didn't know much about the
small towns and I bought a 4-4-2 w-30
had to get a job just to pump gas on the
weekends just to get extra cash and
hopefully be able to pay for the
insurance did you buy a brand-new no
used even used oh yeah that thing was
expensive huh oh it could go I blew it
up on the Turnpike at 130 miles an hour
but it was a great car in between and so
I'm working and you know what was your
what was your side job Oh pumping gas
okay they had a local Shell station and
one of the little towns outside of Fort
Devens and the guy was a he was a world
war two vet and he had
up a sign I bought gas and there's a
sign help wanna say hey I need cash can
I work for you in weekends or if I get a
day off he said yeah come on in so I was
highly trained I could do oil changes I
could grease him up and it was fun and
here you were Green Beret Special Forces
Vietnam just got done with your first
tour and you're pumping gas on the
weekends that had to be a little bit of
a of like a tough thing to swallow it
was but you know we swallowed it yeah
that's like I got to survive and at the
time I was just I still had a sweet
thang down south okay so she was dealing
some issues I'm up there this whole
things falling apart and Boston Boston
was so anti military I mean it was just
peace freaks galore I went to town twice
and I never went back because it was
they could tell that we were in the
military because our hair was still
shorter than the average hippie in
Boston not a good time so we just stayed
with our guys dira bars we had a few
engagements in the bars but yeah it's
good to get out of there and we ended up
getting in trouble for some of those
engagements yes we did I'm told that the
MPS came by cleared base the day before
they got there and I can so I know
taking the Fifth Amendment on that one
this is the SOG operation that will
remain secret indeed so you were a
little bit on the lam you're a little
bit on the run yes and so you run to
two-year to this woman in DC is that
where she was oh yeah at the Pentagon
there was a woman in charge of SF orders
for Southeast Asia
her name is Billie Alexander she's one
of our Saints you know patron saints
there was there was a woman that that
ran the officers that detailed the
officers and the SEAL Teams for a long
long time honestly she did it for 40
something years really and yeah I mean
is the exact same thing like if you if
you knew her and she was always great to
me and I mean she was very nice to me
and she took great care of me probably
because but I was just lucky enough to
have some senior people that knew me and
you know put in a good word but she was
always very nice to me but I saw what
happened
some guys that maybe she didn't like so
much it was rough
so it sounds like you know you showed up
with some flowers and a bottle one she
liked and you went this is independent
in the puzzle palace at the pennant yeah
yeah same thing yes I think yeah this
know this woman like I said this woman
was always super nice but she she willed
it a lot of power you know in inside
inside the seal officer community Wow
cuz if she didn't like you well she was
right in your orders oh yeah and if she
liked you then you know it was like you
know when if you were neutral then what
you know she you're gonna do what she's
gonna do but yeah it sounded like mrs.
Billy Alexander was the same type of
thing oh yeah I drove down all night got
there right in the morning at Pentagon
open and walked in this is before any
metal detectors mm-hmm walked in ask the
guy where she was went down gave it a
wine two flowers please give me orders
came back at the end of the day drove
back all night you're just going all the
way to the Pentagon to try and get
orders back to Vietnam not many I'm told
not many but there were some their self
guys it really felt more comfortable and
they wanted to be there and there's
there's I wish I could line up the
stories but they're like Billy wall and
others that have gone to her over the
years and gotten her song as they wanted
yes she took care of SF yeah that's all
I told the story the other day I was
kind of I there's an there's these so
there's that woman who's the civilian
that handles the detailing but then
there's a there's a seal officer that
would kind of work with her side-by-side
he would get rotated out every couple
years
well when 9/11 happened I knew that guy
and he was he was a guy that I had
worked for he's an officer and he was a
great guy and I had a lot of respect for
him and we got along very well and as
soon as 9/11 happened I called him and
said hey you know I was going to college
at the time I said sir please get me
outta college and be back to go back to
the team right now I don't need to
college I'll finish it online or
whatever I said just please get me back
to a team and you know he said listen
this Wars gonna last long time but I was
having a conversation with him a few
months ago with him and his wife
actually and I was saying oh yeah and
remember when I called you and I asked
you to please send me and he said he
said everyone called and it made me feel
like that's pretty awesome like he
doesn't like you know I guess in my mind
I didn't think I was special but in my
mind
you know I really wanted to go yeah oh
did everybody else every other seal that
that that wasn't in an out of seal team
everyone wanted to go when the war
happened everyone to go do their part
you know yes Bree decor yeah yeah
absolutely and he was right the war
lasted a lot longer than any of us
thought it would so you get your orders
back to Vietnam you're what you do with
the car well but I had to get rid of
four four two traded and got a little
f-85 three-speed on the column it's a
survival vehicle yeah and so so I just
parked that and dad took care of it
while I was gone and some went back
there just went home and said hey I'm
going back to Nam I had no leave time
cut burned it all up
previously and so I went home and broke
my mom's heart and told Dad going back
to my sister ran me to the airport the
next day and then we're back to heading
back to Vietnam yeah your mom must have
been would you dad think well you know
dad was a I'll support your son mm-hmm
and as to his credit he never he never
had an opinion never asked a foreign
opinion because he had a he had
deferment throwing a war family de firma
because he had to run the family
business and then my uncle flew over to
hump so we had family service and but he
says good luck if you need anything let
us know
and I mom was just like she's a little
bit more emotional but tough old farm
girl from Central Jersey Dutch farm girl
you know any and even even then did they
know anything about what your last
deployment was like no no we never
talked about it just glad you're home
yep glad to be home where they had no
idea what kind of what kind of
situations you had been in no we really
couldn't talk about it and like I missed
that you were not on air but you know
many years later my dad came up to me
and said you know I finally read across
the fence and it says now I know why
this guy came by and took our trash so
he said yeah so they got there those
guys a tall black guy he come by and
pick up our trash so he had to be from
the FBI because their check
my trash to see if I wrote anything that
is a violation of the the agreement that
we signed in Danang the 20-year
agreement you won't talk about it won't
write about it and they checked you on
yours so dad and they this guy picked up
the transporter once could dad recognize
her he saw him down at the post office
once near the FBI office so he figured
the FBI guys check it on my Johnny
that's a sidebar yeah no that's that's
that's kind of crazy that they're
putting all that effort to do that and
and yet you you there you're out pumping
gas well that crazy yeah yeah like baby
I gave a great new job though buddy you
came and you guys drop agree she needed
yes yeah it's awesome yeah
that's crazy I like Indy that's uh I
guess when I'm older now
like you know when I was a kid I worked
at fast food restaurants you know what I
mean I can and now I think man I would
not want to do that right now know what
the funny thing was I had a little 25
like a little brownie 25 boys caramel
pop this is Boston there's still some
people that were like less than friendly
up there I said I hope I get robbed I
just want to kill me a robber but no it
didn't happen so what did happen we got
you back to Vietnam
indeed so you get back to Vietnam going
back to the book here the casualty rates
for SOG Recon teams were the highest for
any unit in Vietnam we all had our close
calls and thus each of us was given
ample opportunity for the truth of this
observation to be incised on his sole
none perhaps so more so than the young
hard-charging 1-0 of our team Michigan
Sergeant Eldon bars well no one who ever
met him doubted his professionalism or
determination he was not only meticulous
when preparing his team for a mission
and a fearless leader went on the ground
but he also possessed a biting wit and
an absolute intolerance when it came to
fools and ramps fools and ramps being
a redundancy his way of thinking so this
was interesting because you you talk
about bars well and in the story that
you tell he they're they're out running
up and he finds a vest an ak-47 vest and
he wants it and he wants the aka just
found him laying around in a bunker or
something so he puts on the vest and he
gives the a que to one of his one of his
ended and then he ends up getting shot
in the chest and that that vest actually
saved his life because it hit one of the
magazines that was in the vest correct
crazy story and what was interesting so
when I was in I was in Germany in 1998 I
was stationed at Naval Special Warfare
unit two just outside of Stuttgart and
my boss who is the commander of Naval
Special Warfare unit 2 he obviously
directed to the guy that was in charge
of Special Operations Command Europe and
my boss who I had a ton of respect for
who's an incredible guy a great guy and
taught me a ton he would tell me hey the
the the you saw commander this guy he's
awesome
his name is bars well he would tell me
stories about he just absolutely loved
bars well and talked about him with the
highest respect possible and and he use
it was awesome and I mean I knew about
bars well I mean I basically learned
about him initially from him less
amazing and then later on yeah you know
I would read about him small world and
what a what a you know a great guy he
was and what an epic soldier he was and
what a great example and you know so
many people say he's the like one of the
foremost examples of how you'd want to
be as a soldier just a great guy and I
was lucky enough to have a degree of
connection to to have my boss work for
him when and he must have been he must
have been a two-star at the time I think
it was a two-star yelling at the time so
there he was and I think he did 40
something years almost 40 yeah couple
months shy yeah so that's pretty awesome
to to to read about bar as well oh yeah
you get to this point here where you're
talking about how crazy and I often try
and explain how in combat unexpected
things happen things that you can't make
it up things happen are so crazy and
you've got a section in here where
you're talking about Lin black who's
your running mate for a while for a long
time
yeah then when I left he took over the
team he ran it and when I came back I
went on a team and then he brought me up
to speed
but Dao had changed in five months yeah
and then we took turns and then they
said hey you guys got too much
experience the Lin went to did some more
snooping and pooping and I took over
Idaho again and and this is when he's so
low on the ground you're not there he's
not so low but he's with his team he's
in Laos and they're on patrol they're
deep in enemy territory which is just
like just the way you guys rolled and he
you know the team starts to hear people
following them and now they start you
know stepping up their pace they're
trying to move they're trying to do
things to disguise their trail and all
that
and finally they really like okay we're
definitely getting followed if the two
days
yeah after two days of being followed
yeah and so here we go going back to the
book however before black could give the
word to change course that the noises
suddenly returned only now it sounded as
though a large number of enemy soldiers
was headed straight for them and the
troops were not in the least trying to
hide their movement this is it fought
black the trackers have linked with
reinforcements and they're about to try
and overrun us he immediately told the
team to head for the ridge form a line
and get ready for a fight claymore mines
were putting up quickly into place and
black dug out the radio handset in
intact into anticipation of calling
Covey black was totally convinced he
would soon be declaring a prairie fire
emergency back when black was with RT
Alabama he had faced a map he faced
massive frontal assault waves by
determined NVA so he knew what to expect
and he knew what needed to be done
having moved the team up on to the ridge
line he knew he had the tactical
advantage if the enemy wanted a bloody
fight and it certainly sounded as though
they did the NVA could charge up Hill
and arty Idaho would give it to them
everyone had placed their weapons on
full-automatic and begun and unbending
the metal pins on their hand grenades
the ends were bent in order to keep the
pins from accidentally being pulled so
the ring and hang up on a branch or
something else high explosive rounds in
the m79 were replaced with rounds
containing large buckshot capable of
blasting a devastating hole in any in
the enemy's ranks with everything in
place and ready RT idaho faced the
jungle and waited for whatever was
coming the frenchman caught sight of
something approaching but the vegetation
was such that he couldn't get a clean
shot at it he figured it was someone
moving in a crouch because it only stood
about four feet off the ground he could
see other similarily poised figures
behind it all moving noisily toward the
team in a few more feet they would reach
a point where the jungle thinned out and
he'd figured he'd have a good shot at
them like any recon man Letourneau had
fought about such a moment the moment
when an outnumbered team was forced to
make a stand thus like all the other
arty idaho members he was very tense but
ready for anything
anything that is but what stepped into
the clearing he couldn't believe his
eyes he found himself staring not an
oriental gentleman in pith helmets armed
with ak-47s but long armed hairy reddish
orange creatures with the decidedly
human features it was a small band of
orangutangs probably a family of them
they had been tracking the team out of
natural curiosity trying to figure out
what these hairless apes were up to in
their territory yeah that's probably the
happiest monkeys they ever saw oh yeah
yeah for sure
III was in Sri Lanka and we got to see
that they would there you would hear him
coming and they would be moving through
the trees and it was really cool just
just how but there yeah you'd hear all
this noise and it would be a bunch of
monkeys coming through the trees and
when we had that surround war yeah
we got online we were ready for the
assault in this like we got overrun by
monkey all right now we're getting to
the point where you so that was that was
Lin black working on his own and now
we're getting when you return when I
returned to CCN at the end of October
1969
I immediately reported to sergeant major
John Hobbs and asked if I could rejoin
Artie Idaho
he said that Letourneau had just
completed his torn returned stateside
there was an opening for an American and
I could fill it but linen black jr. is
still the one zero and you two are both
experienced one zeroes I reminded him
that I've been away for five months and
needed some time to get back in the flow
of things I added I'd be happy to serve
as blacks 1/1 for a while because I
respected his judgment as I have put now
you go and meet with the team as I
approached I saw black and Sal leading
the team away from the range once they
caught sight of me their faces lit up
and there was a rush of feelings of
greetings as I shook blacks hands hand
the team surrounded us dancing about
almost like children and the
good-natured taunts instantly began
flowing hot and heavy the gross insult
being one of the most accepted ways a
recon man can show affection I was
subjected to a whole litany of them
aimed at everything from my intelligence
to my sexual orientation in the midst of
it all black totally cool as usual asked
if I was back on the team yes sergeant
I replied I'm reporting for duty I am a
new one one I know more about the team
the AO and the [ __ ] in camp oh sorry
you know more about the team the AO and
the [ __ ] here in camp than I do
I want I wanted black to understand
I was willingly putting myself under his
command and that my goal was not to
challenge him but to learn from him a
recon man who thinks he knows it all as
a recon man headed for trouble and if I
could capture those that attitude right
there and distill it among every person
that's moving into a leadership position
like this the the humility that you show
here the willingness to subordinate your
own ego is like the best sign of a great
leader when you check in
situation you go you know what I don't
know everything and by the way if I
think I know everything I'm wrong and oh
there's someone that's been here for a
while guess what cool I got no problem
working for you I'm here to support
I'm here to I'm here to look out for the
team I'm here to help the team win not
here to look out for my own little
agenda so that was awesome and I was
livin black he's just an amazing man and
so I totally respect to him and was glad
that it worked out thanks to Billy
Alexander order cut get over there
pretty quick and with Lynn you know he
had done a tour duty with the 173rd and
his lost a brother there and he still
came back because he wanted to get his
fair share of NVA dead just to take some
personal revenge and you know we had
that mission where he came up against a
10,000 and survived Mason's mother one
of our amazing heroes and so yeah I
respected them and then later on we
began
there's no SOP the sergeant major Xavier
asked us to do an SOP yeah that sounds
like a that's something that we need to
start doing the SEAL Teams to you
there's another here's another section
in here where you start talking about
well
it appeared to me and we were actually
talking about this before we start
recording and that's when you go to meet
the new commander and here we go back to
the buff because I hadn't met the sea
cien commander I polished my jump boots
de spit-shine hoping they might make a
positive impression when I met him later
that afternoon the call came down to
meet him I put on the last pair of
starched fatigues I had in my possession
put on my new green beret and the
spit-shined boots so there you go you're
getting squared away and again this is
one of those things where you're in your
second tour in Vietnam you know you're
an SF guy you've been in all kinds of
really tough situations but you're gonna
meet the commander okay cool be humble
get the squared away uniform on try and
make a good impression the commander of
CCN made it a point to say that he
ordered Recon teams to break contact
with enemy forces and continue the
mission I knew that several other Recon
teams had been unsuccessful in getting
the tanker so this guy's a tanker this
guy was a tanker he I don't know what he
want you want to give us a little
briefing on what the new commander was
like yeah he was
sign there and he was a friend of
general crate neighbors who was the
overall commander Abrams had seceded
Westmoreland as the top commanding
officer for all of Vietnam and he was
one of his buddies and so in order to
build up his career back Abrams sent him
to an SF unit so he get his build up his
medals get the time and at that time in
the army if you served as Special Forces
much longer than six months as an
officer your career was done you would
not get to promote as the West pointers
and the other guys that would get your
career was just finished but if you had
a certain amount of time and he came up
there which we learned later was to
build his metal portfolio and we had
some other stories that go on later on
so he never really adjusted nor did he
apparently understand SF and the way we
worked but tippy on a recon team and the
whole thing about break contact and team
mission well sir if you're with me on
the ground and you want to say that
that's cool but if you're up there 5,000
feet and telling me to break contact a
team missing with a six-man recon team
we got 10,000 guys wanna party know well
you can't quite say it that way yeah to
go into extreme PC mode yeah and you
know we're just meeting each other -
it's like I heard he was a it was
lacking compared to this previous
commander we had there yeah and the idea
you know I think it's Patton said the
commander in the field is always right
which is a great thing to lean towards
from your perspective when you're up at
5,000 feet or back in its act
cooperation Center you kind of assume
that your guy in the field is making the
right call and try and support them and
there's so many times where I read the
stories that you write or the stories of
the other guys that you're writing about
the the difference between the team
being overrun and killed is a minute
it's two minutes sometimes it's seconds
you know it's like these of the time
when you got when the fire as you're
taking off the fire consumes the area
we're just and that's followed by the
NVA so often these situations as soon as
they started to go bad even in the
slightest way it's like okay we got a
story
start figuring how we're gonna be out of
here because if we try and fight by the
time we make the decision so if you try
to do this idea of his which is break
contact and then continue the mission I
mean you is it really possible for you
to break so you lose a bunch of your
ammo what do you figure a fetter do your
mo half of your ammo in a quick gunfight
and now you think the enemy is just
gonna walk away and the fundamental flaw
here is this is a secret mission it's a
clandestine operation if you make
contact with the enemy quote you've been
compromised but somehow that didn't
compute with the tanker yeah yeah so
you're in there you're talking to him
and and here we go back to the book I
knew that several other recon team
members had been unsuccessful in getting
the tanker to change his mind on that
topic so I approached it from a
different angle I asked him to place
himself in the 1 zeros position in the
field because most of the one zeros I
knew would do anything within their
power to successfully complete a mission
if the tactical situation was conducive
to it but once compromised
it was often militarily difficult to do
so with a six-man recon team against
large numbers of NVA soldiers he
promised me to think more on the topic I
saluted and returned to the team room
leery of the new CEO so you did you even
had a even at a young age you had the
had the kind of understanding maybe I'm
not going to approach things head-on hey
you know you're not trying to stir your
dumb that's a bad idea
no it's like hey you know sir from my
perspective as a one zeroes what we see
it's a little bit different I just was
impressed with the fact that you were
playing the game a little bit to try and
build a relationship with this guy
trying you know spider parks and Pat
walkers that F would be one we a couple
officers are there they're real
[ __ ] in the beginning and when they
took over command if they would be
making bad decisions and didn't
understand a situation but at least
majority of the senior officers meaning
a major or a lieutenant-colonel our case
majority once they've been there saw
what we were up against in the field it
just took a while little time gap for
when they land they want to prove
they're a hard-ass they want to be a
good CEO and they got to worry about
their career too and between that
reality and what we're dealing with on
the ground and
usually most of them came around this
guy was not one of those that was didn't
have that capability
he was just seen it in his his own
perspective yeah yeah I had learned from
the pros you know Spyder Pat Walker's
John McGovern these are all senior NCOs
and I watched them in situations dealing
with sergeant majors and s3 particularly
on mission stuff before the mission and
afterwards how they would talk and I
picked up a lot of I like to think I
sort some of their PC skills because I
had none and there and what would you
say the goal was from a leadership
perspective as you're talking to these
guys I mean I always say look I'm if I
got a boss my goal is to try and form a
relationship with me so that he listens
to what I'm saying because if I go to
iron bud heads out of the gate they're
not gonna listen to me if I tell this
boss this tanker hey you don't know what
you're talking about well he's not gonna
listen to another word I say but if I
say hey sir Roger that I want to give
you some perspective on this that I've
said you know whatever you're just
trying to talk to him with respectfully
try to build relationship that's what I
try to do yeah and with the CEO they
just tried to stay a hell away from
Gilda sergeant major because they'd been
all been on the ground they had
experience and they appreciate what we
were doing they knew what we're doing
day by day our sergeant majors were
squared away with a sectional one but
most of them was I dealt with and we're
just really lucky so I try to deal with
them keep the co site
stay away from was the best way officer
avoidance sir officer avoidance that's a
good one moving forward a little bit in
the late afternoon as black and I went
over the final mission preparations
Junkins came running into our hoots with
bad news our team Maryland has been hit
Walton Brown door down jesus H Christ I
can't believe it wall told me they that
they told him it was a dry hole give me
your PRC 25 someone said they heard
Brown on the radio as I screwed the long
antenna into the PRC 25 black ass
Junkins any word on a bright light team
he turned to me with the frown on his
face no word yet replied Junkins but I
want to go if there is one we all moved
outside to get better radio reception on
our FM radios the news got worse
Junkin said he could hear covey talking
to brown all the Americans were down and
being overrun Junkin said he heard
Covey's last conversation with brown
when a wounded Brown told Covey they
were being overrun he said he heard
ak-47 firing and then there was radio
silence all communications with RT
Maryland were lost the weather over the
target closed in precluding any bright
light missions for 10 days when a bright
light finally went in team members found
on the American web gear near the last
lone location of RT Maryland
no further evidence of the team was ever
located wolde brown and sergeant Donald
Monroe Shu the newly appointed team
member were listed as presumptive killed
in action the loss of wold brown and Shu
was a reminder of just how deadly the AO
continued to be in SOG as always the
Recon men talked to each other afterward
to see if there were any lessons to be
learned from their loss while the
weather was bad sergeant major John
Hobbs suggested to black myself and a
few others in recon that perhaps a recon
book should be written containing and
documenting the team's standard
operating procedures so there you go
that's when you got started on that -
close your limbs it's a phenomenal he is
a phenomenal artist and so he would do a
lot of sketches and then we worked on
every SOP from everything from just
getting pre-mission
what what you would carry would break it
down between Americans in a ditch
batteries claymores five-second fuses
and then adapting to the AO you're going
in some of the areas and layoffs they
had a lot of words that you only carry
one tent canteen of water and
purification pills and other times it
was dry you had to carry more water
which is more weight it's always tried
to stay low as possible and that as one
of the fluctuation weight factors that
we had some control over how much were
used the carrion at least 80 to 90
pounds back then and we women it was
your body weight ah I think it's about
170 soaking wet maybe 175 but the most
after R&R and you were carrying 80
pounds 90 pounds yeah because I carried
the radio plus the 600 plus rounds for
the car am sitting iron rails and the
frag grenades and you guys no war no
body armor
oh no no helmet the body armor back then
was this clunky stuff yeah and it was
just you know and the helmets just made
too much noise and his weight and in the
jungle would just get caught up with
stuff where is that I just wore to crave
at all the time and then try to cover my
blonde hair again this is uh you know
every time I read one of your wanted one
of the stories that you write about you
know you made it out you know you you
you you had that extra Claymore that
gave you enough time to get on the bird
you laid down that extra fire the the
the airships showed up in time to put
down cover fire and and here with these
guys with Artie Maryland like those
seconds didn't happen those aircraft
didn't show whatever the case may be and
that's what was at stake every single
time you guys went out there right and
just like we said in across the fence
all the Americans were killed the in
digital effed alive so they were hit by
we assume sappers and with the
indigenous it's a psychological thing on
all the troops in camp you have to deal
with that again but like over my team we
just pulled the team together said hey
tell us what you heard we know we don't
have a problem with you guys but what
this happens just be advised keep Lynn
and I and appraised of anything you hear
that could be negative or troublesome
then we'll squelch it right away or deal
with it in this case did the ended the
ended make it out so they never heard
from again or no two out of three made
it out one was killed as they came out
of the forest they were near marine
compound of some sort and because they
were in ditch when he came out armed the
marine took him out and the other two
were able to surround
surrender and make his gestures of some
sort that they were able to get picked
up came back they took him down to
Saigon for the full debrief and
everything and did you guys ever get
word on that debrief way late were they
only thing we heard was from Covey and
cobby said that they had the team is set
up for his rest overnight spot too early
and he thought was a dangerous spot but
the one-zero didn't listen to him and so
everybody was surprised that we he did
it because Walt had been a10 for a few
months
he'd been in Marine Corps first came to
SF and then he ran a few missions out of
F would be one that would be one
shutdown he came down to fo before CCN
would you guys always know who the Covey
was who the Covey rider was going to be
no no sometimes it fluctuated
particularly after we went down that
food before because the Air Force
changed their pilots and all the cubby
riders we had an F would be one got
reassigned somewheres else so none of
them carried on it's cubby riders no Pat
walkins came home he D rose down spider
parks came to see CMB hit another
assignment and I saw a spider very
little because I couldn't tell you what
his assignment was he just saw each
other so little there because Lynn and I
were busy running with the cubby rider
do all the mission planning with you
know though he the cubby Rider
and the pilot would be in for the final
briefing at base or at the launch site
and we just talked about L Z's any
anti-aircraft because they continued to
bring down more anti-aircraft everything
from the 37 mic mics to the heavier
anti-aircraft artillery that came in
later did it did they ever get did the
Covey's ever get shot at and shot down
always we have someone went down and
there's a what altitude would they fly
at well they would do everything from
way up high when they're just doing a
general recon
- when the team would be on the ground
they would have to spot the team either
through smoke or mirror or from a
location you have you'd be on a
prominent point that they could pick us
out well most of the times would be
signal mirror mm that we'd flashy up to
him they'd lock in on us that way but
once they got to doing actual coverage
they would come down really low and
sometimes Nappanee earth stuff and there
would be OH - there's slow movers and a
little push pool yeah you know we lost
several coffees it seems like those I
mean I can't imagine being the coffee
rider in this one for our team Maryland
and you're you're there and you're
you're basically watching your guys get
overrun and I mean it is even after you
maybe made suggestions that they move
somewhere else but you know well they
don't but you're still supporting them I
mean what a helpless feeling that's got
to be rough and most of the covey riders
were guys that couldn't operate for
whatever reason no they were well they
were former SF so sometimes would be SF
men have been in country for eight or
nine months and then they would be
signed to cubby rise so they had
experience on the ground there were
short timers so the viewed as as a job
that was not quite as dangerous as being
on the ground but it had its own hidden
dangers yeah yeah and it seems like you
you just want like someone that you
really knew and trusted
oh you're copywriter right and so like
in my case we had a bunch of new ones so
this cubby rider was great he just
picked everybody up ran as well we had a
couple others that we dealt with and
some of these guys like spider parks
there's a couple times when there's no
air available so you say what hell load
they get they would make a gun round
with a car 15 spider would hang out the
window fires car 15 at the NVA I don't
even know what to say to that yeah yeah
and he wasn't the only cubby rider did
that I mean other guys who drop around
for an AM City nine doesn't really try
to do to give us support while we're
waiting for the air force and the other
arrow sets to get there you know I was
thought so when I went to sere school
no they don't they taught us how to
signal with the mirror but then in my
mind cuz I'm dumb I would think like I
think like how well this is really gonna
work
hey I can't believe every that's like
your primary signal device absolute was
the signal mirror yeah every time that
we had been on the ground for a period
of time had to reconnect everything was
all signal through the mirror and we had
to get the flash you get the copy on the
right side so he could see us giving it
you know everything oh yeah big is that
mirror so it's just a regular signal
mirror like a maybe 5 by 3 3 by 5 yeah
like a cellphone did you have I had this
even though I didn't really believe in
signal mirrors I guess I had this like
special signal mirror that when you
pointed it at the thing it got like a
little shade there's a little circle in
the middle that got a little shade on it
when you be in the right spot you know
what I'm talking about yeah I don't know
I never figured out how that quite work
guys want to get the flashy up so they
could see it did you like the technique
where you're aiming at your hand and
pointing at the thing at the aircraft no
I would just make sure we had too flashy
and just point it in general I didn't
get that high level training you had sir
well thank God I did never have to do it
because I probably would have been able
to pull it off well triple canopy is a
little different than a desert
yeah yeah and so in the Triple Canopy
that had to be a challenge too
oh yeah it has we find a hole in the
jungle to get through with the flashing
in the first place then you had to get
the cubby lined up with your hole and
then with the mirror flash you would you
would look at us nowadays and think we
were we were weak with all the crap that
we've got we got laser pointers we got
little signalling devices transponders
on your equipment there's no question
about man not to mention your knob we
would have run over both of our mothers
photos not oh yeah yeah for sure oh yeah
and you guys had some starlight scope
did you guys have some starlight think
they're big and heavy we never carried a
feeling no we only used them for what
couple teams did I couldn't even tell
you which ones I never heard about it
much at least with Ethel b1 or our time
of CCN but we used it for ambushes and
they were so bright then you know they
ruined your night vision so one
be blown out for them from the green
sensors that they use to amplify the
light and then your other eye was for
night vision okay awesome stuff you
after this after Artie Maryland
disappears going back to the book next
morning Hobbes asked me if I would
courier a packet of sensitive
information to Mac V SOG headquarters in
Saigon you end up going to Saigon you
end up doing a little bit of Thailand as
a time in Thailand as well she had a
little pass it sounds like you had a
good time there of which you don't
remember a lot true you get back to
Saigon and you're waiting for a return
flight to Danang you'd spent all of your
poker money which remind me never to
play poker with you and here we go back
to look for some reason I couldn't fall
asleep that night in Saigon I lay there
on my bed looking at the ceiling
watching the ceiling turning still not
believing that I had returned to Vietnam
and a SOG at some point I remember
thinking when I was in Nam during my
first tour of duty I dreamed of
returning to the States when I finally
got home I found myself drawn back to
Nam of course there were pressing legal
matters at Fort Devens that contributed
to my leaving the US of A and as I lay
there I found myself asking myself what
the hell are you doing here you could
die it's like realization yeah that's
the dental scene from Apocalypse yeah it
is it is a Martin Sheen yeah that mental
tape replayed many times in my mind that
night in many different forms but the
essence of the issue was when I was in
Nam I wanted to go home
when I was home I wanted to go to Nam
once again I thought of home where other
than my family there was no compelling
reason to return I had no job waiting I
had no job no career to speak of I
imagined going to one of those County
employment centers and saying hi I was a
1:0 in a secret war that I can't
talk about I can fire my car 15 from the
hip real good and I can hit it target at
400 meters with my sawed-off m79 and I
could bring napalm so close that it'll
suck the air out of your lungs thus at
the age of 23 I had my midlife crisis
there's a picture that one of my platoon
chiefs told me about he had this mentor
Vietnam SEAL who was a mailman in
Imperial Beach California
oho and you know he could come home from
Vietnam and become you know what am I
gonna do he became a middle man and he
had and my platoon chief said that that
guy had a picture on his wall and it was
a it was a taken from the behind of a
guy in fatigues with his web gear on and
his weapon slung and and you're and he's
looking at a like a corporate guy in the
desk and the corporate guy is looking up
at him and the caption underneath it
says I'm sorry sir we don't have a job
here for pointman exactly which it
sounds like how you were feeling this is
perfect on point yeah yeah and you're
you've got this and this is you know
it's interesting I was just talking to
one of my buddies and he was saying look
you know sometimes I hear people say oh
I loved being in combat and when they
say that I kind of get pissed at him and
I think you know if you loved it so much
are you saying he says I don't I don't
love it so much you know I had a hard
time with you know it was hard and I'll
do I would do it again if I had to but
I'm not dreaming about it and so we had
this little conversation when I ended up
saying to him was I said well when I was
on my last deployment to Iraq any others
you know we had some guys wounded we had
some we had had that one guy killed at
this point and there starts to be like
you start seeing those negative feelings
start to start to grow a little bit you
know guys start questioning stuff guys
start hey you know what what do we do in
this operate whoo-hoo
what why are we doing this mission and
then you start to feel that and then
guys start can be start to become
negative and one of my platoon
commanders came to me and said you know
hey man you know this is gonna be rough
and we get home these guys are gonna be
you know we might not they're gonna be
mad about this there could be mad about
that they can be mad about something
else and I said let me tell you what's
gonna happen I said when we get home
when you talk to them three days after
we get home they will have forgotten 10%
of the bad stuff and in a week they'll
forget 30% and in a month they'll forget
50% I said in a year the only thing
they'll remember about this deployment
is the fun cool stuff that's and that's
kind of what I think makes guys like me
say man I I had a is awesome I would
love to go back of course because we
block out you know some of the hard
memories and for me I also always say
the absolute best time of my life was
being a tasking of commander in the
battle Ramadi and the worst time in my
life was being a tasking of commander
into battle or Mahdi because there's
nothing worse than losing your guys and
so it sounds like you that was hitting
you sort of mid deployment of hey look
oh you wouldn't you were home when
you're back in America
you got you got money problems you got
girl problems you got law problems you
got what all those problems and they can
all go away yes they can all become
insignificant as soon as you get on that
c-130 and fly back overseas and I
thought about hepps I'll hung that too
on and the team I genuinely had that
guilt feeling of them there of me not
being there with him I felt as as a
green beret I should have been there
with him all along but we had the tour
duty as you know and so I was in a way I
was really glad to be back on the team
but yes a little bit more mature now and
thinking a little bit maybe two months
but that night in that hotel and then 20
years later when Apocalypse Now comes
out I go like how the hell they get in
my head for that scene
you obviously--you you you get through
that that apocalypse now see of staring
at the ceiling and thinking you know
every minute that I'm in the bush every
minute I'm in this hotel Charlie gets
stronger
cuz he's out in the bush you get back
and you're on another mission and I'm
jumping into it right now as I snapped
out of my snooze you're asleep in a
helicopter I snapped out of my snooze I
looked at out the starboard door just as
we flew over the to startle a Laotian
farmers a woman and two water buffalo
the big chopper then hopped over the
hedgerow and landed in an adjacent field
as Engels and I frantically awakened the
rest of our tea Idaho I was mad as hell
it wasn't bad enough they hadn't
bothered to alert us as we approached
the target area but now they were
compounding that faux pas by flying too
close to indigenous farmers and then
depositing us in the middle of an open
field far from our primary LZ and
further yet from the bridge that was the
primary objective of our mission that
this particular mission was a pretty
simple one at least on paper which I
take it with a serious grain of salt
when you say a mission is a pretty
simple one yeah
by early 1970 the brass had become aware
of something new and rather creative on
the part of the NVA underwater bridges
these were being put in in place at
strategic spots along the Ho Chi Minh
Trail where it ran through Laos from the
error would appear as though the trails
were interrupted by water in some places
several feet deep yet it was apparent
that the trucks had himself were
crossing these streams with ease a
closer review of aerial photographs
however had revealed that the ever
inventive NVA had come up with an
underwater structure that could support
heavy trucking while remaining virtually
unobservable from the air it was a
devilishly clever idea and well executed
to boot so that's pretty they just built
these leg weather like maybe like six
inches underwater the bridge yeah and we
looked at the pictures you couldn't tell
they really done it well and so that was
the mission simple going find out what
they are take pictures and blow them the
hell up simple mission yeah if you'd be
more fun to blow them up with a truck on
it and you were you guys were asleep in
the helicopters head in there no one
woke you up and the reason why we
launched from Thailand the weather had
been socked in in Vietnam so it was a
bad weather spell which was February of
1970 and they flew us by black birds
which were the clandestine service
airlift for us foods to Thailand we land
in Thailand which is neutral at the Air
Force Base the black truck comes up we
get in has curtains they can't see us we
go back to the base and my old commander
from fo b1 was the CEO at down launch
site which was the 46th Special Forces
Group and they were there just to be
in-country but they had their site of
the sequel war spatzle came out of there
they had cubbies out of there and so we
launched and the air force at the h2 h3
is the bigger helicopters like the Jolly
Green Giant but a scaled-down version
without the armor plating so we launched
from there and we flew for two or three
hours because the long flight from
Thailand across western lay offs and we
launched as we landed at a fuel dump in
the middle of Laos yeah it was run by
the agency
okay so we manual yes we refuel but you
get off you go hey man who are you
because I'm not here I go welcome I'm
not here either he says have a good day
while you're not here and we get to go
in and then the Air Force put us down on
that thick canyon and that's one thing
that's always interesting when you're
using helicopters the helicopter when
you're supposed to insert at one spot
for them they they miss that spot by a
minute or whatever for them it's no big
deal like they they just flew a minute a
little bit long for you on the ground
that minute is a long
time I mean that can be a kilometer it
could be like a really massive amount of
space that you just missed oh yeah and
this is like the dip between the valley
and the peak that we want to go in on so
we could run at night a little bit cuz
there's some open areas that we could
cover and then get down maybe at the
middle of the night to check this thing
out in the morning at first light that's
what our plan was just didn't happen
we're in the valley and it's like okay
we've flown out here I so you don't want
to just fly back isn't everybody off
let's give it a shot
we're here we're on the ground scope so
we had to get out put our gear on first
we didn't even have our routine insert
where everybody goes out on full alert
we get out put the damn equipment on and
then we're like okay we're in the valley
and the mountain we want to be honest
several thousand feet above us and we're
in this valley are you carrying a
regular topographic map is that your
primary means of navigation yes and they
would have the big map and then our
target where we plan to go they would
cut out a ten by ten cut it out and
that's what I saw we carried so we got
caught there would be nothing else
besides just that that grid that we were
in and did you ever use any imagery as
well to to know compliment that nope
strictly map the Covey pile if they did
it via our visual reconnaissance prior
to the mission but here it wasn't we the
cubby had told them here's the target
area for some reason the Air Forces went
down to the valley job just there
alright continuing on given the rather
undistinguished nature of our arrival
I'm sorry undisguised nature of our
arrival we knew is only a matter of time
before hundreds of NVA troops trackers
and dogs would be purring down on us on
that road looking for us so you know
sweet to work with dogs so like I can't
imagine knowing going in that I'm gonna
be facing dogs that are coming after us
and obviously you guys were cuz you guys
carried mace and pepper and all this
other stuff to throw them off but what a
nightmare that is I still hate dogs
you have wife loves him but and the kids
love him do you have any dogs yeah we
got a fleabag running around the house
his name is Gunny butter weights it's
like we got it from a from a Gunny okay
yeah ours was no tourists John
furthermore is very unsettling to be
moving through this beautiful Valley in
broad daylight at what for a recon team
past at breakneck speed it was not
comfortable way to proceed
we took no breaks not wanting to spend a
moment longer than necessary in such an
exposed position so you're just hauling
ass oh yeah trying to get out of this
valley as fast as you can and you end up
with going up a hill a big hill and we
just put the team to for a while I put
the ankles on one side the valley and me
on the other it wasn't that big in terms
of width but wide enough that I could
see him he could see me just I want
divided and then the tail Gunners took
care of our foot footprints and what was
your reason for that call
I just wanted to split the team up to
see what was on the other side the
valley we couldn't tell what you decide
what was there so I figured we could any
enemy we wanted to find out on both
sides at once and try to get to a point
where we could begin to find a spot to
get up the mountain cook we were gonna
run out of daylight got it
so it was a little bit of a panic now
panic move it was it was a hey we're in
a tough situation one of the best ways
we can get out of this is we put teams
on both sides of valley we're looking
for a way to get it to the top of this
thing I knew you talked about this
earlier now I used to warn guys all the
time about splitting forces oh yeah and
it's like really risky really really
risk is the one rule you never do I did
it twice okay so I just wanted to
confirm that oh yeah no absolutely and
the the situation was such that we
couldn't tell what was on either side so
I figured we're gonna have a firefight
at least now they'll be minimal forces
are four we went in an eight-man team
that I start falling for four and four
and John had been on the ground with me
previously so he I wasn't worried about
John and so if we're gonna have a
firefight let's do with minimal forces
we could survive and then get the
prairie fire and I'm worried about
getting out of here otherwise this
proceed be and
covers much ground because that mission
where we set up the ambush we had we had
a great success by not stopping because
the NVA knew that we would go ten stop
ten and so they would anticipate how far
we traveled here it's like we covered
maximum ground hauling ass yeah all
right now you end up finding a place to
go up this hill and here we go back to
the book by now we are out of breath the
grueling climb with all our combat gear
was starting to wear on us and each
additional step seemed to bring an
increase in the steepness of the incline
it was growing painfully clear that
those periodic volleyball games we had
played back at camp weren't sufficient
physical training did you guys what you
guys do for PT back then not enough
[Laughter]
volleyball get some yeah that was it
yeah because we're so busy yeah between
a mission mission prep and then they
started thickness in isolation that's
gonna ask you would you would you be
tired when you're going into the field
or would you be well-rested because like
on this one you fell asleep you guys
were all asleep oh yeah I'm gonna tell
you right now like when we would go in
the field most of the time when I would
go in the field especially in Ramadi I
would be exhausted by the time I went
the field because we'd spend all this
time planning and D conflicting and
briefing and doing all this stuff by the
time we'll in the field it was like the
time for me to go okay hey someone
someone stay and watch I'm going to
sleep for an hour or two hours you know
that happened a lot yeah we usually had
a nice rest prior yeah it's nice oh yeah
absolutely
very nice going back to the book however
any thoughts of letting personal pain
slow us down or not so subtly
overwritten by noise noises we could
hear from the north of us the menacing
sounds made us forget our dry throats
heaving lungs pain means and knees and
aching backs the enemy was out there and
the game as they say was on the forces
might not yet be joined but the fight
was in the offing so he knew it was
coming and then you guys go into like a
series the sau leads you guys into like
a serious of vines thorns undergrowth
and we went in and then we went in
deeper and he pushed us the third time I
was pissed but God tore my fatigues I'm
going
you know did the dinky dal like you're
crazy you're pushing it he was right I
was wrong I mean when in the third level
yeah and and and then you get in so deep
eventually settled down and tried to get
as comfortable possible on a 40-degree
slope around 2200 we heard numerous
trucks on the main road in just a few
minutes several had driven slowly past
our remain overnight position
unfortunately the happy times were
spoiled when we soon heard the barking
of tracking dogs around 0 100 we heard
enemy troops moved north on the road
while on the east side someone opened
fire with a few ak-47 bursts the
distinctive bark of the Russian made
weapon jar dust into full alert how long
could they keep it up in which direction
would they move we sat in the inky
darkness a darkness so complete I
couldn't see my hand in front of my face
it sounded as though they were making
their way north
that's how dark it is and you have no
night vision is just pitch black again
it didn't take long before we had enemy
troops on both sides of us as dense as
our cover was we could see the
flickering light from the lamps the NVA
carried as the enemy soldiers began
probing the bottom tip of the finger we
were on vehicle activity on the road
picked up noticeably this game is a very
uneasy feeling had sound not driven us
on the NVA might well have spotted us
but as it was we responsed so deep in
that god-awful thicket that one that the
one enemy soldier who approached our
position hesitated and then gave up
defeated by the phony vegetation we
could almost feel him thinking better of
it and deciding to return to his
comrades little did he appreciate how
close to death he'd come with 5 car 15s
and an m79 aimed in his direction slowly
the NVA troops tired of their
frustrating and uncomfortable search and
called it off our tea Idaho could
finally release the collective breath it
had been holding the danger was not gone
not by a longshot but just briefly
retired from the field of play so thank
God you were deep in that bush oh yeah
and I you know I forgave Sal because
it's like this is we don't need to go
that far it's like look at my fatigues
I'm bleeding here
he's right Sal was always right I always
listened to him so the night goes by at
first light our options were severely
limited we couldn't move north south or
east which left us one choice not
wanting to spend another day and night
tied to trees on the side of a hill we
opted for the obvious and moved out in a
westerly direction for the rest of the
day we climbed the side of the steep
mountain did you guys ever move at night
or do you guys try pretty much to remain
in one position at night try to stay in
one position whoo we only particularly
in a triple canopy it's just too much
noise in Cambodia when we were on flat
territory we could have moved and we
thought about it but no not in Laos
several times the rock face was so steep
we had to tie together six foot strands
of rope we used for Swiss seeds to make
rope long enough to advance up to the
next level of rocks so we're talking
serious terrain Oh Harlan just as last
light was fading into darkness we
reached the top of the mountain I was
physically beat my pants were torn in my
hands knees and legs were covered with
cuts scrapes and bruises we were a mess
we set up our ro Ann quickly and took
turns eating rations before settling
into the night watch rotations after the
previous night nights ro n this Mountain
tight mountain top site was paradise we
could see enemy trucks moving south but
did nothing about it
we were almost too tired to think an
extremely dangerous condition to be in
went on the ground rest was what we
needed
not confrontation you guys are exhausted
beat
when we climb to take our web gear off
rucksacks oh really we tie into all the
squished seats together because we're
going straight up so one guy would go up
and then you shift up the backpack then
the web gear put it back on go to the
next level so we had to take that
straight to shuck it several times and
just to get up because it was so steep
but it was covered but enough vegetation
they couldn't see us in the valley so
they weren't quite sure where we were
and we had put out the mace and stuff
another little cases was found some of
the dogs noses so it's an all-day climb
and with only a couple when we broke for
lunch and whatever but yeah that was a
nasty nasty climb when morning came we
awoke to a beautiful sunrise and found
that we were atop an unbelievably
gorgeous Laotian mountain range the next
few hours were the most spectacular ones
I ever had spent on the ground in any AO
moving north along the ridge line we
began gradually descending often
encouraging one beautiful new
encountering one beautiful new Vista
after another around 1200 we found an
area overrun with thousands of wild
orchids in full spectacular bloom back
home each plant will be worth five to
fifty dollars we decided to take a break
in the field and soon everyone with the
exception of Sal was in the middle of
them and acting like a delighted child
picking the flowers and sticking them in
their hair teeth and behind their ears
or in the buttonholes of their fatigues
it was like a spontaneous outburst of
happiness and while it was somewhat
foolish it was also refreshing I think
we all felt better for you to take any
pictures and no oh man I'm sure yeah oh
yeah you had the camera for the
underwater bridge you can get the
orchids misawa's all business Oh always
he's living on the railroad come on
whether it was your nickname did they
call you tilt as well
no these you called me my because the
Vietnamese couldn't handle ours so
instead of Meyer it was my got it
I could see him looking at you thinking
my what are you doing with that damn
flower your hair their phrase was buku
dinky down very very very stupid very
crazy yeah how good your did your
Vietnamese get it sucked
I had happen and that was why we didn't
have language training because they knew
that with SF but for years for 64 to 68
they were interpreters in place mm-hmm
and we just lucked out with happy it was
his best one East Book good English and
he corrected my English
he spoke French what was his background
that he had all that good language skill
his dad is sent to school in Paris so he
has some education in France they spoke
four languages and now he's an
interpreter Nam yeah going back to the
book we came to a narrow strip of land
that headed down from the hill I single
Dingles and child to set out to scout
ahead while the rest of us remained in
place Chau was 16 years old he'd been on
the team nearly two years so these kids
have been on the team since he was 14
years old yeah when the team got wiped
out Chau Cal and sown where the three
did we'd hired and brought on and we let
a couple of those go he'd been on the
team nearly two years ever since Spyder
parks and help field
rebuilt the team in 68 Chau sensitive
ears heard the NVA moving up the
mountain he warned ingles with hand
signals and the two of them abruptly
stopped moving with the enemy less than
ten meters away ingles quietly broke
squelch on his URC ten emergency radio
several times alerting me to the danger
the rest of us were about fifty meters
away the [ __ ] was about to hit the fan
because we were so far removed from all
air support there was no time to waste
none at all we needed to jump on we
needed all the jump we could get on
things so I quickly contacted a nearby
ov-10 Bronco and declared a prairie fire
emergency setting in motion the string
of responses that could save our lives
and get us out
does everybody did everyone know is that
like a pro word prairie fire emergency
did everyone know exactly what that
meant a Karen knew it right and then we
also had the airborne command control
but they weren't always over aria
they couldn't pick up the Fox mic FM
mmm-hmm so in this case we lucked out
that OB 10 was I think they were one of
the Ravens who had they were surprised
supporting another CIA operation it was
further west into layoffs and he had
been up heard the call and came over and
I was the first time he worked with ob
tens man lucky berry
while I was talking to pilot chaozhou
and Ingalls to spring a hastily arranged
ambush that startled on the startled
enemy troops when their point man was
less than a meter away
tchau hit him with a full automatic
burst from his car 15 blowing him
backward chow silent ingles then hit the
remaining enemy soldiers so hard and
fast that they didn't have time to fire
a single return shot Ingalls threw down
a hand grenade down the hill to
discourage anyone who might be around so
this is all son that's happening a meter
away there is really close and he came
up the hill he was white because I was
the first really real firefight that
child been in and because he had trained
up and like here the earnest spotted
team so this was his mission and that
was he was down in with John and he was
ahead of John as the fight began to
unfold I took stock of the situation
there weren't too many places for us to
go within minutes of the broncos arrival
the pilot had spotted us he said he
could see more enemy activity north of
us along the hill angles and Sal were on
he made a run on the enemy
concentrations firing his rockets into
their position then he said somewhat
laconically I've got two bits of bad
news for you first
nam is socked in no assets can launch
from there to extract you which means
thailand assets which means at least
three
hours before the birds arrive on station
second to yourself that are
approximately a dozen troops about 800
meters out and moving towards you I
think you better sit tight until we get
some help by 1430 a covey aircraft
replaced the Bronco and repeated this
sit tight suggestion he agreed the
eastern and western face of the mountain
were too steep to descend he also
confirmed the NVA were coming at us from
the south and north
they were clearly visible as they moved
cautiously through the sparse vegetation
for the next half hour the enemy troops
tried to locate us to discourage them I
directed several AE a1 e Skyraider gun
runs south of our position so this is
another one of these things where I got
a like when you get you got the NVA
moving to your position and you get told
hey the closest extract the earliest
we're gonna be able to get you out of
here is three hours from now
yeah we're up on an area where there's
minimal escape routes or a jungle
because everything was so steep on
several different sides that had little
work a little bit of a plateau door had
been like a trail that came down and
then John and Chou had gone down further
another little finger and that's where
they had the firefight they came back up
we put a perimeter out and luckily we
made radio contact right away so the
ov-10 went in with his rockets just to
say it was 2.75 and then that's when he
gave us the good news yeah good news
that's gonna be three hours at a minimum
before they get you help
yes why we carried a lot of bullets yeah
a lot of that it could be a long day I
don't know if you can carry enough
bullets for a three-hour fired fired
that's a nightmare back to the book of
12.7 millimeter enemy gun in the valley
opened up on the a1 'yes i was sitting
on the east side looking down at the
valley floor after making another gun
run that a1 e pilot told me he was
pissed because the enemy gunner was
coming too close to him and his wingman
he wanted to nail him ASAP i gave the
pilot what I thought was clear what I
thought
clear verbal directions to where the
enemy gunner was located but he couldn't
find them so I told him simply to watch
the ground for my and follow my tracers
at that I fired a short burst toward a
clump of trees in the valley that were
maybe 500 metres away the pilot had no
trouble seeing where my tracers hit
thanks partner he said in a low southern
draw and then rolled in for the kill it
was the most beautiful napalm dive I've
ever seen the pilot came out of the sky
pointing straight down his engine
screaming it reminded me of dive bombers
I had seen on the television series of
victory at sea I really thought I was
watching a World War 2 movie because I
was so high up in the mountain I was
looking down on the sky Raider when at
the absolute last second he released a
napalm canister and pulled out of his
gutsy dive it was a perfect strike the
impact generated a secondary explosion
which was probably the Gunners spare
ammo going off around him black oily
smoke billowed up there was not a
whisper of sound from the former gun
emplacement for the next three hours I
directed air strike after air strike
around our position and in the valley at
1730 hours we heard the very welcome
sound of the HH 3s coming our way as
they approached in the distance the NVA
pushed up from the north and hit Sal's
claymore further south of us another
machine gun opened up from the valley as
I gave Covey the compass heading to its
position I caught sight of an enemy
soldier climbing a tree about a hundred
metres away he had handed his RPG
launcher to a nearby comrade while he
got into that position it was clear he
was looking for arty Idaho or hoping to
nail an Air Force chopper I was too far
away to shout and alert to the other
team members for the first time in my 16
months of running missions I extended
the collapsible stock of my car 15
normally it remained compressed to
minimize the length of the weapon but
now I wanted it extended to help
stabilize my aim once I was ready I
carefully put the NVA soldier in my gun
sight in that fleeting moment I felt
like God I had the power of life and
death concentrated in my finger
tip as I grounded my elbow to steady my
arm I found myself silently hoping the
NVA troop would be unable to find the
team and simply climb back down the tree
he didn't see either me or my car 15 in
a troubling way it seemed unfair or
unsportsmanlike but war is not designed
to be a sporting contest if the
situation were reversed I had little
doubt what he would opt to do although
these reflections took less than a
moment to form they caused deep
soul-searching on my part I found myself
recalling my third grade Sunday school
teacher mrs. Myrtle Richard and her
treatment of the ten commandments
especially the one that proclaims thou
shalt not kill hell if I had met this
treed soldier on the streets of Hanoi
without guns and beyond the rhetoric of
politicians we'd probably be able to
find lots of common ground between us
and dozens of purely human things to
talk about but that could not be not now
not at this given moment also in my mind
was the knowledge he would receive a
medal if he ever managed to kill me or
one of my team members as I watched and
reflected his comrade reached up and
handed him a rocket launcher I could
tell it was unloaded what I had what I
had come to think of my personnel my
personal NVA moved a little farther up
the tree craning his neck to find us
from the corner of my eye I could see
Sun move towards Sal and at that very
moment someone passed up around for the
RPG I still refused to yield to the
inevitable I continued to hold on to the
stubborn hope that he would abandon his
cause climb down the damn tree and walk
away instead he fitted the round into
the end of the launcher I still watched
still I waited even after he'd put the
weapon to his shoulder as he nestled his
neck against it and began to take
careful aim toward us I leveled my sight
on his head I pulled the trigger a
single yet timeless
he dropped from the tree out of sight
but not out of my mind one of those
moments hmm
how far was he away it was arranged he's
well over maybe a foot football field in
half two fields because I was like on a
cuspid as' of the hill and he was around
on the side and I could see there was
like a tree he climbed up that was above
the regular vegetation so I'm not sure
how high he went but I could see him the
beginning and then I just waited because
then when he got that damn RPG mm-hmm
yeah then it's time to do what you got
to do oh yeah and once again I'm gonna
make this claim I'm not reading this
whole book I'm jumping around and you
should read this whole book if you're
listening to this because I'm getting
10% of what's going on in here this part
continues on seconds later one of the
approaching h/h three pilots broke broke
into my reverie by commenting somewhat
frantically on the heavy ground fire he
was taking from the mountains south of
our position there was a moment's
hesitation before he sadly announced I
think we have some mechanical problems
we're going home we could see the
helicopters and they looked fine to us
they were less than two kilometres out
when they turned and disappeared into
the fading Sun our morale sank as they
vanished after cursing our lack of after
cursing our lack of look and the pilot I
told the team to take a nap there's
gonna be a long night so there goes your
ride out in there for freaking ever and
you see those guys hey we got some
mechanical problems we're out of here
yeah it's a very unhappy moment
[Laughter]
so you guys you tell the guys to take a
nap you take a little nap yeah and back
to the book around 1930 Engels roused me
wake up you're not gonna believe this
[ __ ] as I came around he was pointing
south up the mountainside from about 30
meters from our perimeter and as far as
we could see there were dozens and
dozens of lanterns bouncing and swinging
along each Lantern was carried by an
enemy soldier and between each Lantern
were many more soldiers the same scene
was unfolding to the north of us the NVA
were coming up the hill on mass we could
see at least a dozen trucks unloading
hundreds of NVA troops in the valley
also across the valley and up on the
plateau to the east there were hundreds
of lights moving everywhere like
swarming fireflies flitting around in
the night in a smaller valley west of us
still more lights more NVA
more trouble just more more and more of
everything we did not want to see I felt
the tremendous weight of just how small
RT Idaho was how terribly isolated and
alone we were how incredibly vulnerable
all of a sudden I found myself praying
for reasons only he understands my
prayer was answered as a few minutes
later the first Spectre c-130 gunship
arrived on target with its - 20
millimeter cannons and four 7.62
millimeter mini guns ready for action
that had to be the most horrifying thing
that you could ever think of you wake up
and you see these enemy lights
surrounding you hundreds of them and you
know that they're looking those hundreds
maybe thousands of enemy personnel are
looking for you and your six-man team oh
yeah no comment for us and it was just
like yeah I'll never forget when Jon
woke me up I mean it's just one of those
moments he's just like
my god [ __ ] me to tears and help me Lord
yeah please wake up you're not mom keep
praying right about now if you fit not
praying back in New Jersey please start
praying now and then what what do you
have any idea did you ever find out what
where the c-130 came from where the
spectre came from it had to be out of
Thailand and so it just randomly showed
up Oh No then somebody with the cubby
that we had talked to earlier who
brought the hill and copped us out
because the cubby was still trying to
work with us for other air SS and when
it got dark we lost everything
conventional so all to a ones phantom
jets were gone and they didn't have
helicopter gunships out Thailand just
transport vehicle of aircraft so we had
that quiet spell and so they had
notified Spectre and they had told me
that they're gonna try to get a Spectre
out and had you work with the Spectre
before yes we used before but nothing
like this night so for anyone that
doesn't know to a c-130 Spectre gunship
is it's a it's a c-130 which is like a
big transport aircraft but they put some
big weapon tree in this case - 20
millimeter cannons and four 7.62 minigun
which fires six thousand rounds a minute
correct or something crazy oh yeah yeah
it's like a little I can lay xur beam
when the tracers come out of these
things or a dog piss it from the sky
yeah or that and so these guys show up
and here we go back to the book this was
this awesome a way of array of weapon
tree could be made to form a magic link
with my emergency strobe light once that
link was established the gunner could
dance the incredible firepower of his
four mini guns just twenty four thousand
rounds per minute total within five feet
of us it was wonderous it was miraculous
it could save us on this particular
night however we were faced with a
highly unusual if not unique problem the
pilots circling over us reported he
couldn't pick out the teens strobe light
because there were so many other lights
surrounding us the myriad of lanterns
must have made the dark earth look like
a pin cushion illuminated from within no
problem I said I'll turn off mine you
get the rest hit the ridgeline west of
the valley give me a minute to put my
team on the safe side of the mountain
the specter commenced to putting on an
amazing display of firepower
once again we gave thanks for being on
the right side of the fight the one that
had Uncle Sam's Air Force and Spectre on
its team after ripping up scores of body
and carving out large patches of empty
darkness on the ridge line The Spectre
directed his deadly fire into the valley
more lanterns were snuffed out and the
darkness spread like a stain as lights
and lives were extinguished The Spectre
crew finally expended all of its
ordnance and the pilot apologized for
running out of ammo the next Spectre
arrived seconds later see they've they
were just they knew you were in a bad
way and they were common oh yeah we were
so happy that the second one showed up
because now the lights are out so we
could turn the strobe light on and have
direct , did they have night vision back
then in the spectres oh yeah okay at
everything yeah see Air Force yeah yes
it is yeah I mean this the Spectre
gunship is just the most awesome asset
to have overhead for ground support
because the capability the visual
capability that it has and then the
accuracy of fire yeah this is 1970 you
think how accurate that was oh this is
what they can do now oh yeah yeah
the next Spectre arrived seconds later
he quickly locked on to our strobe and
worked the southern slope with a
vengeance marching his guns right up to
the trail right up the trail to the top
of the ridge beyond our line of sight he
worked then he worked a valley in the
southeastern mountain ridge a third
Spectre arrived and worked our southern
perimeter again systematically walking
its fiery lead up the mountain around us
there was no longer any light above us
no moon no stars the only sound was the
roar of the c-130 overhead in the
absolute darkness he could not be seen
until his guns opened up then tongues of
fire seemed to erupt out of nowhere like
spontaneously generated bolts of
and the outlines of Spector's fuselage
would appear in brief flashes as a pale
and ghostly silhouette an airborne Grim
Reaper
when Spectre moved to other targets we
could hear the enemy dragging away his
dead at 0-0 forty-five sow said some NVA
were in the grass about 20 meters south
of us a few minutes later he blew the
claymores we all instinctively flinched
for some reason claymores always sounded
more thunderous at night and caught you
by surprise after the dust settled we
again heard NVA troops dragging away
their bodies they never spoke we heard
no cries of pain their silent execution
of grim duty was at once eerie and
admirable Jesus they were tough they
fought hard and died hard so you
wouldn't even need hear these guys
getting wounded getting blown up and
they wouldn't even scream they wouldn't
cry we just silence
it was amazing today it was
mind-boggling think that all those guys
were wounded or just dead ok the dead we
know but there had to be some wounded of
course not a sound but you hear them
dragging the bodies and we I don't know
how many we killed that night
back to the book shortly before the next
Spectre arrived
I moved my team away from the edge of
the slope and into the high grasses Sal
placed one more Claymore down on the
northern slope in short order Spector
locked on to our strobe light he
reported that cloud cover was beginning
to roll in the AO
when Spectre dropped when Spectre then
dropped illumination flares over a Sal's
eyes turned as big as pizza tins NVA
troops were then 5 metres of us all of
about 15 feet blinded by intense white
light they could not immediately make us
out as we nestled into the high grass
but this was of little real consolation
they would spot us soon enough I
whispered into the radio asking Spectre
just how close he
could bring the ordinance to my
strobe-light as close as you want it
he first replied I want it five feet in
front of my southern perimeter I
responded well he hesitated I can't
bring it in any closer than 25 meters
from your perimeter unless you're
willing to accept responsibility for any
casualties we may accidentally inflict
we have to record you saying it I wanted
to scream you dumb [ __ ] idiot they're
five meters away and you're going to
quote and you're quoting regulations to
me just kill the [ __ ] before they
kill us instead and feeling like a
complete fool I whispered that I was
fully willing to accept responsibility
for any and all casualties that may or
may not result from his efforts to save
our lives I followed up by saying now
bringing it in as tight as you can to
the light I'm holding it up now move
south from my light I'll take my chances
with you the gun crew finally opened
fire in there and the fuselage cracked
over our heads the ground in front of us
erupted as thousands of rounds ripped
into it kicking up stones and dirt and
tossing NVA soldiers around like
ragdolls against Spectre slowly marched
his stuff southward from our strobe
light moving up the ridge danger-close
oh yeah
so the flare goes off and South sees
that the enemy are 5 meters from where
you're at yeah I didn't realize they're
that close they were that quiet I mean
they kept coming all night and because
it was pitch black and they were just so
quiet and they just probably moved
during the wind or moved during when
rounds were hitting or whatever and they
made it to within 5 meters I mean that's
when you're making this radio call it's
a miracle they couldn't hear you and
they just didn't start shooting towards
your direction when you make the radio
call that's why I was waiting for I was
waiting for that next a.k to open up all
my voice especially when they're asking
you for the oh yeah oh ho
you talk about moments that's insane
totally I wonder what - I mean that's
I'm actually surprised that they could
pull off five meters maybe just for
anyone that's listening that doesn't
understand this this aircraft I don't
know what what altitude were they at do
you have any idea there had to be at
least three to three thousand feet above
us so and I don't know what the height
of the mountain range or that that
little plateau that we were on there but
several thousand feet above us they
locked in
neurontin input rounds within five
meters of you oh yeah yeah I mean I
could see they do it now because now
they've got computers and they've got
all these I mean just incredible systems
up there I mean I've been in the modern
ac-130 they're ridiculous well is that
right yeah yeah they're crazy like
they're the the the capability that they
have is just completely ridiculous but I
can't no I mean I mean I know there's no
way they had that same technology back
in 1970 it's impossible you know there's
more technology and in my phone than is
in of 1970 bird those Air Force guys
were good and you know we just kept a
strobe light right pointed at the
aircraft so when it's circled the
whoever had the M sitting on I did it
for a while then we take turns with it
but we always followed the aircraft so
it would be directly linked into that
strobe light that's right because you
had your you put the strobe into the m79
right yeah so it was only directional
right so we go straight up there so
anybody in the ground wouldn't see it so
that's what's happening as these guys
are five meters from you oh yeah
this is ridiculous that's what I thought
that night also hey yeah send me a king
bee please yeah
back to the book between bursa fire he
dropped more flares this time the
illumination revealed no movement south
of us instead ciao gleefully reported
that there were beaucoup dead VC with a
South quiet Spectre started on the
northern flank and marshes fired down
the finger of land when I reported
hearing more trucks in the valley the
gun crews pounded them into silence
another Spectre circled us and laid down
its deadly Ring of Fire again bringing
it to within 5 feet of our strobe light
somewhere around 0 400 summer early
morning fog and haze moved in as the
last Spectre moved out once the spectre
was gone the NVA started moving toward
us once more from the south only this
time with real vengeance Spectre killed
a lot of their comrades and they were in
no mood to back off but we managed to
hold them off by employing what we
called our guess whether I'm throwing a
grenade or not tactic which had a way of
making almost enemy almost any enemy
think twice what was that all about
I didn't covered in the book but you
wrote about it but what lost another
version of hide-and-go-seek with could
we only had a limited amount of grenades
we had used some already and so we knew
that when we threw the grenade when the
land that you'd hear them rot that you
would hear so we knew were getting low
so Sal went out and got stones and chow
and had the team went out in Gus stones
somehow they came back so we wait until
he would tell us somehow he shall could
just tell where they were I could I
didn't have that kind of definitive
skillset so his signal he would let us
know or he would just throw the rock he
thought of rocky here and scurry away
like rats could they thought the grenade
was coming so we throw another rock so
it'd be less scurrying so then we wait
throw another rock and be less scurrying
then we throw it another hang grenade
so in then this went on for quite a
while you know we always carried at
least 10 hand grenades I always carry
these 10 our ditch every 10 yourself oh
yeah sure I had a couple on a strap and
always in the rucksack and that's why
just for that mission yeah apparently
little did I realize you needed 30 yeah
we abstained from firing our weapons
because the muzzle flashes would have
marked our position too clearly for the
RPG Gunners who had fired several
inaccurate rounds at us during the night
fortunately they hadn't come very close
we played these deadly games with the
enemy until sunrise at one point we
broke a major thrust by tossing a white
phosphorus grade grenade then one of the
most fearsome things I know of we
couldn't see them but we could smell
burning flesh at around zero 6:30 we
heard an NVA officer or senior NCO
calling roll in the distance
it appeared few people answered him as
the Sun finally burned off the fog we
worked tactical air strikes with
phantoms and Skyraiders a couple of
machine gun position to open fire and
hit one of the a1 E's a phantom blew one
of the gun crews to hell with a
500-pound bomb that a1 e knocked out the
second one minutes after it opened fire
because there were no more Spectre
aircraft to call on I continued to
working with a pair of a1 E's having
them make run after run I could talk
directly to the lead pilot and he and
his wingman
executed my every request or Direction
flawlessly damn you had to love those a1
e pilots finally we could hear in the
distance the sweet sweet sound of
approaching helicopters big HH threes
churning their way our way it was time
to pull out all the stops I used every
available support aircraft F Force and
a1 ease to raise hell and suppress enemy
fire as they roared in with guns blazing
we could see the 8h threes tagging along
in their wake I told Covey to have the H
h3 gun crews focused their fire on our
southern prim
and we'd handle the northern side I also
requested a land as close as possible to
the North Slope and not pay any
attention to the claymores explosions
we'd be setting off I didn't want to
spook these guys off so the the helos
land every one of the team once aboard
immediately went to the starboard window
or faced out the tailgate and began
firing on full automatic as the h h
threes revved up to full power I was the
last to leave and before heading for the
LZ I set off the last Claymore we had
put on the northern perimeter then I ran
like hell bent over like a [ __ ] and
cursing the propwash that was trying
hard to push me backward as I made my -
I remember being surprised and not
seeing a single dead body although I
passed a slew of blood trails and saw a
lot of dark wet stains on the ground the
second I was through the door the H h3
lifted off the ground
there was nothing but sporadic small
arms fire coming at us and in the end
the extraction was relatively calm one
it seemed as if the enemy was dispirited
and just going through the motions I had
a feeling they wanted us out of the AO
as badly as we wanted to leave
nonetheless we all continued firing on
full automatic we also launched at least
one m79 round as we gained altitude
I dropped my last hand grenade into the
under bush a little something for
someone I hoped then just as suddenly
and miraculously all gunfire ceased the
only sound was that of the churning
sikorsky hh-60 mare force blankets for
the long ride when I made contact with
him he gave me that quick nod of his and
a slight smile we made it again
that's just just this is just an insane
mission oh yeah and I'm sure you you
know what why don't you just break
contact and continue mission so yeah
crazy they need to yeah I know that
you're putting some of these books on
audiobook we're working on in the
process of doing that and these are
gonna be great when you when you release
those I know you talked about in the
little in the book you were putting for
you you requested one of your guys be
putting it for a Silver Star for this
operation it John angle and then you got
put in for a Silver Star as well and
actually you're the the CEO said he was
gonna upgrade that yeah he said he got
on an upgrade which I didn't agree with
but not gonna argue either yeah to a
Distinguished Service Cross which if you
don't know that what that is that's the
the second highest military award for
for valor and so but but at the same
time and and again this is I kind of
have to just tie this back into the book
a little bit but you had been going
through this kind of hassle with the
commanding officer about carrying the
carrying a new encryption device out we
didn't have it for that mission and you
didn't have it for this one
correct but you had but then it he
started turning up the heat like hey you
got to carry this thing and this thing
is no joke I mean I was looking at I
used even when I got to the SEAL Teams
we used a PRC 77 were those around for
you yes what we started with okay for
that for that encrypted transmissions so
there you go so yeah the PRC 77 is an
old radio it's an FM radio and it's how
big would I say it is wasn't what
something is similar to expect 25 yeah
but I'm trying to think of something
that a civilian would know correct so I
can describe it's like a big it's like
two lunchboxes maybe like yeah maybe
like a briefcase that's a little bit
more square a little bit thicker so it's
like that maybe two shoeboxes something
like that's better something like that
that's what that's how big a PRC 77 is
the KY 38 which is the encryption device
is basically the same size as that right
it's like again
and it doubles the weight you got to
carry double the batteries it cuts down
your range because it takes away from
the penetration of the of the radio
waves coming out and you had to carry
the encryption punch so that's what
you're getting told to carry and you
keep coming back and saying hey this
isn't that great
hey we've been trying and it's not
working you you you keep getting told no
carry it carry carry finally you you you
say to your boss
you say the commanding officer Hey look
I'll carry it but if we get in one of
these bad situations I'm gonna destroy
this thing if it doesn't work if it
doesn't work I'm gonna destroy this
thing yeah and he kind of says okay
whatever you know but you carry it yeah
so you go on an operation you you and
you actually we're gonna leave it in the
helos you ask the helos to take it you
and you ask him to come back and get it
because it didn't work he said helos
come back and take this thing because
it's 50 pounds yes the weight and we had
I want to try we were the target was the
[ __ ] and there was there was
something specifically in the [ __ ]
they wanted us to confirm so I went in
with a four-man team the theory being
would go in light we can move quicker
because the A Shau Valley didn't have
triple K at least a part that we were
looking at so like single or double
canopy and a lot of open areas because
if there's so many bombs during an eight
camps to have been overrun deserted and
I've been in the a saw we put the senses
in and plus we fly over it every time so
generally familiar where we were gone so
I said I want to do a four-man team
please don't force me a carry well we've
had to carry it and that's when I said
if it doesn't work we went in tried it
didn't work it started a few times
yeah and they wouldn't come back and
you've been trying it on other
operations as well where we tried on one
and it's just a complete failure but I
brought it back and so this time you
start getting tracked yeah and and you
say okay you know I'm not carrying this
thing anymore
so you put it through my grades you put
a thermite grenade on yeah so you put a
front of my grenade on it you destroy it
and then you again by the skin of your
teeth you got you get
you and your guys out of there and when
you are coming back to you you're flying
back to base and just so you know how
close they were at one point I'm looking
to the north and I see a young face come
through the jungle at me within 2 or 3
feet or so so I can see his outline I
could see his a kay is down he sees me
and we just stopped a look at each other
and it's all through the jungle the
grass he backed out I just kept my car
at him but he didn't open fire mmm and
he was young I mean a young kid with a
gun he backed up and he went away so I
knew that this okay this missus now
compromised and we hit the thermite yeah
like I said you get this is another
mission where you are getting out of
there by the skin of your teeth it's a
damn miracle that you you bring all your
troops back that you don't get overrun
that no one gets killed it's crazy and
they the CEO was flying in a helicopter
close by we asked for a tactical with
rods right he goes break contact the
team is our favorite word's
so we destroyed the the encryption
device Roger that yeah yeah and we've
had more contact well his he finally ran
our fuel went back we're on the ground
for a few more hours we continued to
move but we hear more activity
particularly yet-to-be thermite it's the
damn radio I thought we'd be getting
extracted he didn't so now they know
where we are cuz anybody within 10 miles
can tell there's the thermite grenade
and any are as it's those guys and
they're coming for us mm-hmm but there
weren't a lot but we had a new
copywriter came out Dallas Longstreet
and we started running a once across
because we could hear the enemy to the
west and so the a one's made a couple
gun runs and the last gun run the pilot
came in and then he flipped his aircraft
so like I'm looking at the a1 making a
gun run and earlier you could hear when
they go by and how the aircraft makes
these noises these crack noises when the
wings change and the whatever the
structures in the plane are so I'd heard
him goodbye before this one he came by
he want to make sure where we were
he came by so close I could tell you he
was smoking to Felicia root he looked
over he nodded I saluted and he did a
couple more gun runs and they brought in
this and they they split skull and they
dropped the ropes and pulled us out on
ropes and of course whenever you go out
of ropes to shooting at you it's like
target practice for them you I don't no
one ever gets shot on the ropes I mean
oh no we had a lot of guys never got
shot on the ropes not go would just just
luck
oh sure luck I mean I always felt like
they're just coming through your legs
get your balls or mr. happy worse brain
damn you so I'm worried about brain
death this year so you go through all
that and again people need to buy this
book so they can read that full story
because even what you just said is a
portion of it you get back you get taken
out on strings which again there's
something we didn't talk about a lot but
a lot of times when helicopters could
land they drop down the ropes with the
sandbags on the end and you guys were
clipping and they dragged you out
through the jungle and gets you up the
altitude and get you out of there yeah
and that's what happens here finally you
get back and here we're going back to
the book when we landed on the
helicopter pad at CC and the seals
biggest ramp a rude arrogant a rude
ignorant sergeant major told me to
report the co ASAP with the KY 38 and
all attachments for it when I walked
into the CEOs office the REM sergeant
major ordered me to stand at attention
which I did then the CEO asked the
$64,000 question where is the KY 38 I
explained to him that per our earlier
conversation when we had made contact
with the NBA since didn't work I
destroyed it he flew into a rage telling
me that I had violated a direct order
from him not to destroy it under any
circumstances I stated once again what I
had said prior to the mission because
this was a four-man team he simply said
he didn't remember it that way it was
just me him and the REM sergeant major
who knew that the CEO was of course
telling the truth
so the the the sergeant-major support
and skipper of course oh yeah he's
telling the truth I didn't like the way
this was going so as I had in the past
with the CEO I tried to explain my
actions from the position of the man on
the ground which was different from a
man singing a command-and-control
helicopter as he had earlier in the day
while ordering me to break contact and
continue mission then he got really
pissed and told me that he was going to
write me up from the article 32 criminal
allegation under the military military
code of conduct for willfully destroying
US government property in direct
opposition to his order not to destroy
the KY 38 under any circumstances the
REM sergeant major then whispered
something to the co as they whispered
back and forth to each other
I found myself growing extremely calm
unbelievably calm finally the co stepped
from behind his desk
leaving the REM sergeant major behind it
I'm going to ruin your Special Forces
career I want you out of CCN at first
light tomorrow he went on to tell me to
report to 5th Special Forces Group
headquarters in NHA trang where he'd
have me drummed out of SF within the
next month privately I smiled because
the co hadn't done his homework he
failed to realize that my service in the
Army ended in two weeks due to the fact
that I had extended my time and service
to return to CCM the co only knew the
date when I had arrived at CCN and it
had assumed I had a traditional one-year
tour of duty that would end in October
not April 1970 my SOG days ended right
there I knew that when I went to NHA
trang I could get any assignment in
Vietnam where there was an opening for
an experienced SF soldier but as I stood
there I believed that God had sent this
[ __ ] into my life for a reason
granted it wasn't a reason I didn't
completely understand granted it was a
reason I didn't completely understand at
this precise moment in time but
it was time for me to get out of Uncle
Sam's army altogether while my body if
not my mind was relatively intact who
knew what the future held for SF in
Vietnam
finally he finished and asked me if I
had anything to say you're a disgrace to
West Point [ __ ] you sir
I turned and exited without saluting the
rim sergeant major caught up to me as I
exited the door and told me to return
and salute the co I bent toward his ear
and quietly said [ __ ] you too sergeant
major before leaving the CCN
headquarters area I stopped by the
awards and decorations desk to see if
the co had begun paperwork for flying
that day east of our team embarrassed
that clerk was simply nodded his head in
the affirmative meaning that the CEO was
in the process of getting himself
written up for an award for telling us
to break contact and continue the
mission while he was flying out of
harm's way safely in South Vietnam that
was him yeah Wow oh yeah just don't
believable but you know it's just like
you knew it I just felt it and plus he
had a reputation already by that time
and we had talked to the ad people
previously about some other things he
put himself in for her had somebody put
him in for and yes it's just a total
disgrace and it's just that the luck of
the timing was the fact that you knew
that you could get out of the army yeah
at that point us I was juggling the
thought of relisting a friend of mine
who was a captain who we had run one
mission together he was going to he was
in the process of putting me in for a
direct Commission to lieutenant and so
the paperwork had been placed and I
don't know if it ever got the saikhan or
not but I know that he had a separate
office the paperwork was done we had
completed everything we had letters of
recommendation all that stuff and so in
fact he and I talked about where we're
going to do
is going to stand for a few months to
see if the direct Commission even though
the reductions in force were coming
mm-hmm you know because they had already
started the Vietnamization process the
maximum manpower we had at Vietnam was
at the end of 69 I believe it was we had
five hundred forty three thousand
Americans in Vietnam so by April 70 when
this all happened we had reduced the
nevers you could do more more of it was
coming
even within SF and so that all those
things were being juggled so if I got
the direct Commission I thought about
that two years of college I knew it to
get two more years if I was gonna try it
for a career and and I didn't want to go
back to Fort Devens so those were the
things I was jumping at the time and
when this all happened I just like I
said I was really comma just thought God
gave me an answer here you know going
back to the book I continued down to the
team room where I gave Sal five hundred
dollars to buy food and drink for the
biggest party arty Idaho had during my
tenure on the team we partied late into
the night one by one each team member
passed out until it was just hep and me
standing outside Artie Idaho's
Vietnamese team room HAP asked me if I
needed him for any more interpreting
when I said no he passed out in the sand
I picked him up dust him off as best I
could and carried him into the team room
where I gently placed him in bed before
I turned the lights out I stood in the
doorway for a moment longer reflecting
on my 18 months with these men with a
special affection and admiration for Sal
HAP Faulk
clang and hung then the guilt pangs
washed over me what did the future hold
for them and that had to be the hardest
part of this departure brutal really was
and these guys
we're just doing this continually for
years they didn't rotate out no that was
their job well HAP had rotated up to
headquarters he asked for permission to
go there for a better paying job and at
the three-and-a-half years running recon
says sure and we had a the guy was
interpreter of Virginia came over
not as good as HAP but he was a good
interpreter and by that time we had
worked on two other South Vietnamese
hyung and a Chow were speaking good
enough English where if I got shot they
could pick up the radio take over
because we cross train them on radio
procedures SOPs how to run everything so
help knew how to do it then hung and
then Chow later and they must from their
perspective this must have seemed
completely insane oh yeah absolutely and
they're like really but they knew the
way but this is 70 so SF had been there
in force for six years by then and they
knew enough and talking to each other
plus being in a secret war how things
were operated and that you know we all
report it to a commander somewhere and
it was still one of the points that it's
a sticking point with like oh god I'm
alive thanks to you and now I'm leaving
you guys here and so this is April 70
without everything about what April 30th
1975 would be like the day of Saigon
film just horrible so you you finished
with that you know you you pack up you
report it to NHA trang during during the
next two weeks the most traumatic event
was having the ice cream stand severely
damaged by a enemy mortar fire that was
serious that's really messing with your
head too destroyed the ice cream stand
the reps had to go got they got PTSD
from that one oh yeah daddy go downtown
for the ice cream on April 25th that was
April 1st so now it's April 25th yeah I
mustered out of the army at Fort Lewis
Washington again with mixed emotions I
flew to Denver Colorado to spend a few
days with my sister Linda and to enjoy
some spring skiing in the Rockies at the
end of April she got a rental car for me
to return to New York City I drove from
Denver to Sutherland Ohio to visit my
cousin dunk Conrad and his wife Sandra
before heading home to Trenton
the drive was about 1,300 miles
including pit stops and a long wait in
Ohio for food and few phone calls I made
it home in less than 15 hours see you're
averaging over a hundred miles an hour
basis that's all I could do though it's
just a rental when I arrived at 20 West
Paul I have that's your house where you
grew up it was around 3:00 a.m. times
had changed in my absence my parents now
locked the front and back doors of the
house so wearing my jump boots in class
a uniform I went around to the back of
the house where I climbed up to the
window grab the metal roof of the shed
and stepped on the metal clothesline
hook to push myself up to the red metal
roof dampened by the morning moisture
after I climbed through the back window
I went over to my little brother David
and gave him a big hug hell he was
taller than me then I went down to my
parents bedroom moving first to my
mother's side of the bed I touched her
face but didn't say a word
groggy Shemer she murmured David is that
you then she reached up to my face and
felt my beard John she said as she
stirred from her sleep John is that you
John you're home Henry it's John he's
home
she reached around my neck with the
urgency and pain only mother's know and
said Johnny's home Johnny's home oh yeah
so you made it home
hey buddy grace God and what came next
what I mean what did you do after that
well went to went back to school because
it took me two years to flunk out so
that summer I took classes and then my
dad got me a job right away driving
school buses and so to like within the
first two or three days of me getting a
driver's license this is Trenton New
Jersey there's still some race riots
that were gone on so things were they
had curfews which there's like this is
like mind-boggling in Trenton of all
places and so they said we got a run for
you you're gonna go to Chambersburg
which was the Italian section of Trenton
and they were just starting new
integration program so I picked up a
busload of young black kids that were
mostly elementary school pick him up
take him into Chambersburg on the way in
there's protests and I'm getting rocked
and stoned and I don't have my car 15
because those Italians are whoever they
were they were hitting us with those
rocks it was really making me very
unhappy but here it was like this is
Trenton I go for one more zone to this
and they're doing this integration stuff
so the curfew so we had all that going
on and within a couple weeks the church
softball team was reactivated softball
season was there that did that school
did some driving and actually got
involved in the school newspaper became
editor we had a period of time where the
student government voted his self out of
office we had the SDS on campus that
Kondos were in there doing her thing
behind the scenes they burnt down a
couple buildings just for good luck
played Domino's in a library knocked
over all the books there stupid stuff
there her and then was it you you had to
just be thinking yourself are you
serious
yeah and this is what I just you know
assault my friends get killed took risk
my own life saw what the Vietnamese
people were actually fighting for what
they wanted yeah and you had these
people back here in America do it acting
like this and this to you know we knew
the SDS was or backed with the calmness
and they had their auteur propaganda but
it was never reported they were just
like well here's like another group
protesting in the streets without any
kind of active definition as to who
these people really were what they
really hated America and so you know
we're involved with school trying to get
going and you know during this time we
got very active with the paper that has
editor for two years I worked on a paper
for every day for two straight years and
we had our moments you know they had the
first faculty strike in the state so
before that I was really excited could
me and two other SF buddies were going
to shut the campus down because the the
faculty there and the teacher unions
told us we will support you students and
we're gonna get things for you and they
made other promises which okay I'm all
for it and there would be the first
strike in history in New Jersey and so
me and a guys put together a plan
because there's basically three major
entrances and one couple clandestine
routes so we had everything planned
we're gonna overturn an empty fuel
tanker at one gate the other gate we
were to just close it down with cars and
things so would take them at least a day
or two to clean it up and clear it out
we shut that school down so we're
putting our plans together right so now
here comes mr. editor I get a copy of
the state I go to the State Department
of Higher Education and the Chancellor
gives me what the state is proposing
says look at this read this it says have
the Union give you their proposal but
they wouldn't give it to me nor would
the chance
he felt was a violation of their
fiduciary whatever the hell was that
they're dealing with these union people
so the union guy had his Volkswagen in
the parking lot
long story short I borrowed his contract
I got it
photocopied it when I'm photo cop and
get downstairs at the administration
building he walked by I salute say I
continue to photocopy his is a
negotiating paper which at many pages
longer her I went back in printing side
by side there's two mentions that what
the union was going to do it over twenty
or thirty pages of documents one was to
give them more time off and the other
was for a class size that's all they had
in those pages we printed it dead in
editorial and said screw the Union and
opposed it and then we went to war with
the Union editorially another fair and
they went on strike but they didn't
close the campus down I pull I pulled
our true eyes brokenhearted because I
really wanted to get some some feel of
real warfare here Trenton state college
you know but they lied to us
where were you studying at the time well
you know I was a member as a freshman is
64 and I finally graduated in 74 with a
political science degree with a minor in
English the English was still my foreign
language at the time and did you did you
I know you were working at the paper
that's what you ended up doing for your
career your young career must of my
amazement because at the signal that was
our school paper
I did everything photography editorials
news stories and went down to the
Trenton Times the local paper they were
owned by the Washington Post
dick Harwood was the editor and during
the Watergate stuff he was the voice
that was skeptical of Woodward and
Bernstein but he was my editor it's not
good down and I went in for an interview
I said I had my hairs on my shoulders
now I hadn't had a haircut for a couple
years
blue jean jacket t-shirt jungle boots
old blue jeans going for the first
interview he's interested just come back
for a second I went back for a second
interview had a clean t-shirt at this
time stepped it up yes
I haven't thought about polishing the
jungle boots less than that so I got
hired went to work the trend times I was
there for 10 years and then went to San
Diego for 10 10 years with the San Diego
Union which is about eight years moved
out to California 1985 what made you
decided to move out to California
The Washington Post sold the Trenton
Times and it the quality of the
newspaper just diminished incredibly I
was fighting more with the editors to
get stories into the paper I covered the
courts and I was doing investigative
stuff we did a story about that we broke
the story about the FBI investigating
Philadelphia Police Department
corruption that went to the top why it
interviewed a marine who was a Vietnam
vet who was the undercover guy working
with the fan belt inspectors for 18
months I see this guy at nights we did
this today we did this he made fun of
the FBI and so he told me when they were
getting ready to go out get the search
warrants and do the raid so I called up
the fan belt inspectors and said hey
heard you got a little case going on I
don't want to jeopardize your
investigation but I'm gonna write about
it before you guys do it
let's talk turns out the chief FBI guy
was a as a Specter pilot oh geez he had
flown in layoffs now we couldn't
determine if he was my Savior that night
on February a 1970 or not but we had an
interesting exchange so I gave him two
days and they put all the paper together
and they put up wiretaps on the key
suspects and the Philadelphia Police
Department Monday morning I broke the
story scooped the Philadelphia Inquirer
every major paper in the world does it
before the Communists News Network and
and Fox News and all this stuff did the
story and it was amazing and they and
they did the whole thing when the
follows my one of my major coos we had
the other story about the Philadelphia
Phillies that were under investigation
and so we had law enforcement with my
was my main source that did the courts
and in between we do these investigative
pieces were fun Kane of San Diego was
there for eight year
doing law enforcement covered our
beloved border patrol and then from
there I went to North County and I I
always lived in North San Diego County
and they had a paper called the the OSA
side blade citizen so I went to work
there the editors job paid $10 a week
more than a reporter's job so I was like
became an editor's assistant city editor
up in Oceanside which eventually became
the North County Times and so I went to
work there in October met my future
bride in December she had two boys I had
two girls ten months later were married
and so we'll be celebrating our 25th
anniversary this this October and we
went for the tiebreaker so the
tiebreaker she's 22 now and I worked at
the paper until 2008 that I've worked at
a couple of nonprofits helping veterans
over the last 11 years in between a
couple books for good luck
yeah well no awesome books it seems like
and this is something I always did like
obviously you know you you went through
some just completely insane intense
stuff you come back it seems like you
got back into society fairly well fairly
quickly being you and and what I always
say guys is like you need a new mission
like because what happens when I think
guys fall apart is when they come back
from wherever they're deployed to and
they don't want to come back they don't
know what to do they don't they don't
they don't go on to the next mission
whereas you're like okay I'm gonna go to
college I'm gonna work at the newspaper
or I'm gonna organize these you know
we're gonna fight this fight and it
seems like you got focused on what your
next mission was where I think that's
when a lot of guys don't do well and I
was wondering if you saw anything with
your friends other Vietnam guys that you
served with the guys that seemed to get
back on track and carry on with her life
as well those the guys that don't
yeah majority of our guys I like to
think came back and they just that one
way or the other we had a couple tragic
cases that didn't I mean when I went
back from my second tour I went back
with Jeffery Junkins who was going back
for his fifth tour of duty second or
third with SF and so we held on the
plane going across when
back wheel and in the camera on Bay and
instead of going through the process we
got our duffel bag went out stole Jeep
drove to the Trang but didn't go to
headquarters went downtown and partied
for a little bit then reported to the
track and then went up to CCN there
because we were both be turning so
there's no in-country training not as
tough and and my order specifically said
si si si n and I got back to the team
right away which you covered earlier
here and the other sidebar which really
helped was at trench State College I
point I was a point man for the Pele
wmia concern center they came out with
the bracelets and the whole thing went
there was that effort they had American
citizens that were and the family
members it's the first time American
family members petitioned an enemy to
treat our prisoners better and so our
prison swarm related released until
February of 1973 way at two years that I
worked at the PIO WMI a concern center
we had a POWs Air Force POWs from
Trenton we supported him his well his
family wrote letters everything we could
do for now in our spare time between
classes putting on newspapers and things
like that so it was like a really a
Subrosa mission and when the prisoners
came home that was just a great moment
mm-hmm and so but it really was helpful
like they said another mission that we
went into the newspaper going into it
and there's a period of time the student
government voted herself out of office
so the paper was the only student voice
so we took one zero what does that mean
the student government voted themselves
out of office was that even me hey this
is 1971 we had people that were just too
busy they didn't think the student
government was was a good address issues
that were apropos to to needs and
students or whatever the hell that meant
and I forget the real reasons but they
just disbanded themselves so the signal
was the only voice on campus and so we
became much more active
and of course we had affirmative action
that was starting then and the teachers
strike we had a outbreak of meningitis
which killed three students had to cover
that and of course deep in my mind I
wanted them to strike I wanted to go out
stop the campus down but it didn't work
out how about the you know how was it
the treatment you know you know as a
modern day veteran myself like we get
treated just unbelievably ridiculously
good whereas the benefit from Vietnam
we weren't treated well but today our
citizen tree treats our soldiers sailors
appropriately regardless of the politics
they thank you for the service mostly
yeah we had we had cases I mean I wore
my fatigue jacket for years just to say
[ __ ] you I'm wearing if you don't like
it talk to me about it and we had a few
parties with the newspaper and so
everybody almost everybody except for
one or two people were very liberal of
course this is the college 1971 too and
we had this one freak he's like six
three had his long hair and he came up
to me said you know you guys I know
about you Green Berets your [ __ ] baby
killers you know he's gone on the whole
party comes to a stop so it's mean is
creep and so he said a few more things
than fine says aren't you really a baby
killer and I said look the only time he
killed babies when we ran out of rations
he was never saved and every boss was
kinda like laughs and realized how
ridiculous this [ __ ] was yeah so it's
like why get your hands dirty yeah yeah
so yeah we had someone that I'm in black
when he came back he was trying to get
out a year poor quick and took a took
the door got outside and wound up in a
long corridor well three or four guys
came up to him I say hey man you're back
you got cast we're gonna believe you
that burden so then pulled out was 25
caliber browning the little ones you
know you
your palm yeah the mingoes no you're not
I'm not giving it to you and the guy I
recognized a cigarette lighter when I
see one limb put her round between his
legs right there at the airport they
they left but again there's no respect
you know Lynne just didn't want to get
his uniform where was that where I was
live see up in Seattle yeah yeah and
then how did you start getting reans
group that you're with now I got a phone
call first but well just - I got a phone
call from Spyder parks in 1983 I lived
in Trenton my first wife first order and
he said we got this group special
operations association it's our guy so
it was formed by Green Berets that ran
recon and we had some hatchet force guys
that were the platoon company size
operations like Mad Dog Jerry Shriver
and they had formed up a few years
earlier so I signed up probably to
Trenton and their reunions were at
different places so I'd never I didn't
bother to go for several years but spire
and I talked paid my dues and finally
went to they started having them in
Vegas me and Jeff Junkers we drive go to
Vegas get into the hotel went to the
security guard left and sneak into the
reunion hang out with the guys for a day
pick one of our guys crashed in their
room for the night and then drive home
next day but we get to see the guys and
no money we get to free food free drinks
a little gas right so we did that for a
couple years there's a lot of fun and
then when I finally met Anna my current
wife and my sweetheart forever that kind
of came to a close I took out on one
time and the first time was not a really
completely good experience some of our
guys are still pretty wild and then the
hotel wasn't that cool but now that's
more of a our guys are slowing down a
little bit we've lost some along the way
so we happen to be you know it'll be our
43rd reunion that I'm also involved the
Special Forces Association chapter 38 up
an orange and I went to the restroom two
years ago at Christmastime I came back I
was president
rapido my second year duty with those
gentlemen and what's the what's the
nonprofit group that you have we have
the veterans veterans affordable housing
program that's out of orange and then we
have a separate nonprofit called the
American veterans assistance group where
we work with programs within our
communities we have 45 communities in
the five western states that are owned
by our company and by our nonprofit and
so we encourage to help veterans that
have fixed income to get them into
affordable housing
you know the manufacturer homes are less
expensive the stick houses and then we
have programs but through our the evac
program we have programs for meals
meetings have been a guest speakers and
things like that and we're doing at
about nine of our two communities now so
that's what my other job is to do the
newsletter busy always always busy can't
like Clint Eastwood say can't let the
old man in well I'll tell you what
we just hit three hours or something
close to that so I know I need to let
you get out of here obviously anything
else any other closing thoughts no just
as I said the first time is I could have
done any of the books without my
sweetheart my dear bride you know we had
you know four teenagers and a relatively
new born in the house they go right and
the god bless her without her I couldn't
have done it so and their family today
we just learned we got to to grow two or
three girls are pregnant so we're
getting excited about being a
grandparent or practicing her and we're
still working with our nonprofits so
moving forward anything can people
donate to that nonprofit do you have
that kind of thing is there a website or
anything like that or is you guys just
run it locally
no they I'll have to check the website
but they could I've got my email my
website saw Chronicles calm and they
could punch a near my emails there and
I'll plan to Ford and the we're going
through some changes with our website
where I sign you know let's SOG
Chronicles
is how people can talk to you reach out
to you through that gladly
and yeah come on in and we'll say hi and
take it from there
awesome awesome well well thank you for
this opportunity and your books me love
thank me at all Lewis's this is the
honors 100% and completely all mine to
hear the stories which are completely
insane to learn from your experiences
obviously or maybe it's not obvious
anytime you want to come on the podcast
you shoot me a text you let me know
and we'll just open the door you come in
I don't need to say anything you can
just talk that's fine with me I'll just
listen like a bad dream I'll be back I
look forward through every second of it
likewise and you know so thanks for
coming on and and you know more
important and of course thank you for
what you and what your teammates did for
the service of our great country
likewise sir thank you
we're always indebted to you and men
like you so thank you for what you've
done
appreciate it airborne all the way until
next time and a once again John Stryker
mire tilt tilt has left the building
what an incredible human being and it's
a complete honor and just lucky to be
able to sit here and talk to him and
hear his stories and hear and reflect on
stuff and it's been a while it's been
three hours so anyways if you liked this
conversation this podcast that we just
did mm-hmm
if you got something out of it which I
know I did if you want to support the
podcast while you actually support your
own self yes I think Eko can give you
some help in making that happen
yep yes so it's going to it gg2
obviously I'm doing jujitsu if you're
not doing jujitsu I I would say chuckle
and I strongly recommend I thought you
said we were disappointed no see
yeah maybe maybe part but not really at
the end of the day there is some
understanding to be exercised here
because not ever okay you were rolled
well you're different but sometimes
people roll into jiu-jitsu gym or see it
on TV or I mean think about it
two people wrestling a hard or whatever
some people just don't automatically
want to go do that you know just
automatically on its surface you might
think oh well that's not really for me I
don't really want to gravel grapple with
some other dude oh yeah what you don't
see is what's beneath the surface
yeah because what's beneath the surface
is fitness flexibility mobility mental
stamina yeah physical stamina yeah
cardiovascular improvement strength
improvement on top of all that you guess
what you get a legitimate skill that you
can actually choke another person that's
bigger than you that is stronger than
you yeah you can take them yes so and
you know if I speak for myself the
reason I started and continued with
jujitsu is because it's the skill that
you're talking about you that you learn
that skill is this if someone if someone
insists on fighting you mmm you can win
the fight yeah you won the fight and
before you learn how to fight and I'm
speaking generally speaking um before
you learn to fight you think ah you know
um I'll just do this oh yeah you know
I'm stronger than that guy or I'm bigger
than that guy whatever yeah you know and
you don't realize how how untrue how you
know how I've said we lie to ourselves
yes like we lie to ourselves this is a
whole nother category of lying to
yourself yeah because one category is
like we lie to ourselves like oh it's
just one donut it's not that's just a
lie you lying to yourself or well I
don't like can't make it to the gym
today cuz you know my you know it's
getting a little late that's a lie you
know it's a lie but an even bigger lie
is I'm more capable I'm capable you know
in certain situations and you're not and
you're thinking and you still talk to
people like this you're like oh you know
we'll feel really came down to it yeah
yeah you know
and I lift - yeah and I got strong
cardio who's gonna be able to take me
I'll tell you a most fourteen-year-old
girl yeah that knows how to you know
choke you yeah that's who
yeah just like in pool right you play
pool billiards billiards snooker sure
and it's like yeah I know I see what's
going on I just hit this ball to hit
that ball and go on the thing yeah
that's no problem with money on me I'm
pretty smart I'm pretty coordinated yeah
you know I'm just like that's just
something I'm not how hard can it be
exactly right and you go play against a
guy who really who knows how to play
pool you'd be like brow how do you even
do that like how did you even let you
figure it out but they know they just
know it's not like it's this magic thing
they just sort of know same thing with
jiu-jitsu it's like been in fact it's
such a mystery when you actually do it
how easily they beat you it's such a
weird magic mystery that they you don't
even comprehend it yeah at first you're
like oh oh I just slipped
nobody you did slip people either but
yeah yeah yes and you think oh well next
time I'll just stop him from putting his
arm there yeah 1 billion other things
that's gonna do yeah exactly you don't
know nothing about same thing with
basketball by the way yeah something
with all sport basketball right oh yeah
yeah it's it goes deep anyway when you
do jiu-jitsu when you did you get to
because you're doing that we're doing it
and you're gonna do it you should get
Aggie because you don't you want to gain
okey so the pedigree that you get is an
origin G best ski in the world factually
and made in America which is a huge deal
by the way also origin the brand that
makes these keys they make jeans
American denim you didn't get yours yet
did you no I did I thought to be little
all the time yes sure these little just
got his yeah we sure do you know why we
take care of the customer first well
you're not really because the mine were
T&E you know what that is research and
develop test and evaluation yes to
devalue care yes and I just got another
test evaluation for the next phase yeah
because I'm making another face
we lie to ourselves as a wise man once
said anyway no I don't have genes but I
from what I imagine from what I see and
gather you know from the field they're
good genes see now this is this is a
good psychological good flanking
maneuver you just did right now Pete
Ryan here that's Nell be like Oh echo
doesn't even have genes no no I will get
100% better get them - did you did you
text them and say hey can I get a pair
of jeans size or whatever me and Brian
share text and pain by the way how like
oh we're the last were the only ones
that we literally know that don't have
even worse story a lot of genes and you
know me I'm over here well then again I
wear the the the shark fins sure you
know what are you sure that they maybe
that's all I wear so whatever
representing everything in big time but
they happen and be the best sure you
wear jeans very often me know maybe
that's right not not while you're too
vocal about it yeah me but you would be
if you had them on if I knew like yeah
maybe I'm just sour grapes like I don't
even want any cool all right that's what
I do have them how are you good they are
totally good to go there the next level
squared away awesome yep you can get
genes you can get t-shirts you can get
supplements we have supplements we got
we got joint warfare which you should
take we got krill oil
we have discipline to discipline go this
one go is like get your cognitive wheels
spinning turning moving quickly sharp so
can we have discipline go in a can of
coming out I think he's actually out
right now yeah the little yeah yeah
those are the same formula the one the
test one that they yes okay good yeah
that sounds good yeah here's the thing
about all of these right so you have
joint where for krill oil right the
combo that's the best way to go fleet
joints and then you know discipline and
then the mole can in everything okay
consider this right as you get older and
you still want to fight because man I
got it I gotta be honest with you I'm
you know you know you catch the wave of
just consistency I know you're
consistent person and
I've been on that wave okay it's a
tsunami right so you go you're the
poster child of one although I do have
that I do have the ding knee right now
yes which is we're almost there
yes but you know how okay you know how
some people can catch various levels of
politics a flourishing flourishes of
activity you know where they'll catch
the wave of consistency meaning like
everything they're doing in their life
is like I'm being disciplined and I'm in
the zone where it's like just second
nature now boom boom boom everything
right so if you take all of these
supplements that's gonna keep you on
there yeah especially as you get older
oh I don't know about the older part cuz
I'm just kind of the same as I was just
as how for you but take it from someone
who's getting older
actually getting older oh these I think
I as far as my workouts like they're
hard they're harder than most of the
workouts I did when I was young and I'm
just maintaining big-time as far as like
staying in the game yes thank you anyway
you get the consistent combo that's
that's in my opinion how you do it
also I mentioned Moke additional protein
in the form of a dessert delicious drink
that's just so tasty you know telling me
like the they were saying oh it was Dave
good deal yeah yeah good deal day was
was saying he's at a point now where
he's drinking strawberry milk he goes
listen it's one thing to be okay it's
time for dessert or hey I'm a little bit
hungry it's another thing to just be
sitting around or walk with you're off
some beauties just think for no reason
other than I want to taste the goodness
yeah I'm just gonna go have a strawberry
mocha
yeah strawberry Slayer right now and you
know why I understand because I've done
that before and this is what I thought
the thing is you there's no guilt in
that but here's the thing the concept
kind of made me feel a little bit guilty
when I was doing that because you know
how the kind were you just like at home
bored and you see the cookies and you're
like it was an easy path and you took it
it was a desire that you should come to
yes so that's my hand be
a bad pattern to go down yes so you got
to be careful don't get don't allow the
goodness of milk to start to train your
brain to accept things that you just
want yes with it you can make an
exception with milk you can be like hey
I really want this right now just for
what just for the sake of wanting it yes
you don't lay our mind but I think hey
donut yeah there's a slippery slope bro
it is very good beware the mind said
essentially there's other flavors too if
you don't like strawberry which some
people don't
who is it Jason Gardner like Jason
Garvey since they don't like strawberry
good job Jason he's over there but he
takes that little hitter with his coffee
in the morning he's got a little he's
got his little ritual scenario he's got
going on that makes sense though
strawberry and coffee I guess no not
like the one Elia there yeah then you
got mint peanut butter the peanut butter
is also all folks so is the mint that's
that's the og you know did we just say
og is we did we did big-time it is and
then don't forget about the warrior kid
milk which the word can vote for your
kid either that you can give them poison
you can give them poison which oh you
got a bunch of corn syrup in this drink
I'm gonna give it to my child so that so
that I give them type-2 diabetes or you
can get them something that makes them
stronger smarter or faster or better yes
or your kid or your kid milk strawberry
and chocolate get some also chocolatey
mmm certified organic by the way mmmm
very good micro I would even call it
micro doses of caffeine there's like
mini mini doses yeah yeah there's 60
milligrams per can yes sort of like a
cup of coffee it also has the
antioxidants in there it also tastes
good refreshing very so there you go and
well obviously yeah if you want to
deadlift 8,000 pounds obviously yes a
chocolaty that's thorn also certified
also we have a store Jocko has a store I
said we have so we all have a store if
you want to get your merchandise haven't
said that word mer
I don't really say that word that much
just said it and you said it in a real
kind of illicit kind of way you know why
cuz my daughter watches YouTube videos
which I had to block her oh not blocker
but you know you know how you got to put
the Block on YouTube so only they can
only see certain things anyway I had to
do that she's like you're like okay good
the only thing she's allowed to watch
this jujitsu videos chuckle podcast or
your kid podcast oh no and she can take
it to anyway the reason I did that was
because she was following some girl on
there who's really she was just real
sassy she wasn't it wasn't like the
wrong reason she just had a sassy way it
was talking maybe 15 maybe 16 years old
young man that's my estimate and my
daughter six so this girl is talking
about this and then it's starting to say
this stuff which is cute at first on my
opinion but after a while you're like
hey you can't talk like this is not yes
not what we're doing over know what
we're doing exactly right so she anyway
so recently we didn't left past like two
days we had to block her anyway one of
the things she kept saying was like
merch and she'd say it all sassy like
I'm not gonna do it again I'm not gonna
say it again
but that's how she was saying it and so
I just slipped into your head slippery
and slipped right out of your mouth
about the move that's why okay so what
can you get at yeah Oh a door yes so
choco store.com is where you can get
discipline equals freedom shirts
lightweight hoodies which are really
nice man I had it on the other day and
it everyone to all flash into it and be
like hey this is yeah you know what's
interesting about Jaco store calm what's
that is we sell t-shirts for one thing
we sell discipline equals freedom
t-shirt we sell good teacher we sell
t-shirts there's also people that come
up to me and say ah I just got an
awesome t-shirt I got one of your
t-shirts and I'm like a sweet man mm-hmm
and I just had a guy say to me hey I
just got one of your t-shirts I wish I
was wearing it right now and I was like
cool inglis it's the don't talk just get
after it shirt oh okay and I go cool man
we don't have that I don't have that
shirt yeah
so there are what are we calling
knockoff knockoffs yeah what do you call
like yeah there's like a word for it
it's a kind of junk yeah they're
disapproved but they're kind of worth
call unapproved they're like worse this
is why because people will they don't
know the layers you know how like
remember the layers shirt and you evade
$90 for it and has no language came with
no layers no layers man and that's that
that's really and it's a piece of crap
sure yes so it's kind of like when you
buy something for the kids you have a
reason to buy something right and this
is generally speaking I know different
reasons vary from just person to person
but you have a reason you buy something
right let's say there's two reasons to
buy a shirt one of these shirts hmm no
let's say there's one reason straight up
one reason the main reason is the layers
you can't even literally you can spray
paint this will equals freedom on your
shirt if you're on display you can have
that on yeah you can do that totally can
you can have one printed you can go to a
website and whatever font you want you
can make it look however you want
literally so why won't you do that right
because you want more than just that
there's something in whatever that
reason is you're in the game
what does that reason is we'll call it X
reason X if you go buy stop talking
get after it shirt you literally bought
something else you didn't buy an x check
you out st. been thinking about this one
you know because I there's a whole
reason about it but but nonetheless
here's the thing no because I saw some
should kind of creator you feel like
people are kind of know maybe but
offending you
in this way though because there is it
there's a shirt thing called like it's T
red spring or I don't know something
where basically you can go online take a
JPEG of a picture I can get any one
picture of you online submit it to this
website it'll make a mock-up of the
shirt like that you know the cheap
shirts and you know the buy in bulk
maybe secondhand whatever shirts make a
mock up and be like hey guys buy my
shirt right and I saw your face on it
like kind of a literally the wrong
design right they were trying to copy
exactly but there you've already seen
this yes and I saw it and I was like man
you know done in TJ like they'll knock
off like Louis Vuitton purses and stuff
at least it looks like the Louis Vuitton
logo you know and you got to look close
to seating you know the the the quality
the lapsing quality but this one was
like flagrantly wrong design you know
whoever meanwhile they're like selling
it like their thing yeah it was
offensive for sure and it's offensive on
two levels because of offensive kind of
to us is like hey that's not our stuff
don't misrepresent that's a be the
person who doesn't quite you know
they're just new and fired up they can
be like hey there's one here's the first
one that popped up on Google they're
gonna get the junk one they're gonna go
out try to represent in the wild and
that's just not gonna work then that's a
bummer that is in there's no support no
support and you know I get it you know
support isn't the primary reason when
you think of like you got to go out
there and someone buys the shirt they
there was no but there's there no but
that being said there are some people
that they don't really need another
shirt they're literally just to support
yes sir
plenty of people just hey we appreciate
the time the effort the whatever
appreciate it here's a little thank you
little support yeah nothing wrong with
that that's appreciated that's you know
that allows us to that allows us to have
echo make all these videos nonetheless
the Chuckle story dot bio you knows
listening to this right now no one with
three hours three hours yeah alright
well whatever you're gonna say you might
as well say it that cares but it's all
still true how about that
and yes the mid the stuff that you
really want to represent the authentic
certified there's no certification
process but approved approved is all on
Jaco stored calm IWA active dot co dot
uk' that's if you're in the UK that's
where you get it yeah
so I and here's the thing I'm gonna say
by another URL for that what code uh you
at UK still yeah that's it gotta be like
that
okay anyway cuz you know cuz shipping in
certain parts in like the shipping is
crazy from here is what I'm saying so
boom you wanna you want to sidestep the
shipping a little bit you can do that
might take a little bit longer I think
maybe I'm not sure I don't live in the
UK but nonetheless some people were
asking me about that
oh yeah anyway hoodies and stuff all the
legitimate approved stuff check it out
if you like something get something also
or subscribe to the podcast I mean
haven't already on iTunes stitcher or
Google Play where every listen to pop
tunes or whatever you listen to podcasts
that's what I meant estate and the
warrior kid podcast which is not dead
it's not dead you know which is more
episodes are brewing the brewing in my
mind should I you know I make for the
warrior kid podcast I do a blast I don't
know six episodes perhaps I've done the
story from Uncle Jake
yeah that takes not just time because it
takes a little bit of time to prep but
it also takes the spark of inspiration
right okay here's the deal right and you
can't manufacture inspiron oh no we know
yeah so sometimes I'm like well I could
just do a QA for the kids which is what
it started out as which is fine which I
I get it so but sometimes I feel like
I'm letting everyone down if I don't do
the story from uncle Jake's childhood
yes because I really like doing the
story uncle Jacob childhood so do I now
I will like I said well we're back on it
maybe I'll release some with no story
from uncle Jake's childhood just to
because I get so many good questions
from young warrior kids around the world
and I mean that I think about that the
world little warrior kids all over the
place getting ready to do some pull-ups
so yeah check out the warrior kid
podcast and also if you want to support
a actual warrior kid Kota Irish Oaks
branch comm we're young Aiden is making
soap that allows you to stay clean check
yeah
also we have a youtube channel chuckle
podcast YouTube channel if you're
interested in the video version you see
with just what Jon striker Meyer looks
like tilt aka tilt or if you want see
what Jocko looks like if you don't
already know more if you don't have a
shirt with his face Ari on it and you
wanna see what he looks like on
you know YouTube and also there's some
excerpts on there you know if you want
to listen to or revisit specific ideas
or concepts lessons you know
individually and share them with your
friends you know my higher likelihood of
them watching it that's really the money
on our YouTube channel so yeah EKKO
thinks his videos are good you can leave
a comment on his videos he does read
them I read them allegedly everyone
likes to say that goes so check that out
psychological warfare that's an album
with tracks where if you got a little
moment of weakness you might be
approaching and you want to get out of
bed or you want to get your workout
daughter you want to say no to a
doughnut doughnut press play
psychological warfare iTunes Google Play
mp3 don't forget about the visual
version of psychological warfare warfare
from Dakota Meyer flipside canvas Dakota
Meyer is making art you know that you
can hang on the wall that says all your
excuses are lies
makes all kinds of cool stuff he's
stepping up his game with that it's
really cool stuff and if you haven't
listened to a podcast 115 with Dakota
Meyers check it out and then go get some
of his gear from good old flip side
canvas dot-com it's a very good one I
was talking with both John Bozak
mhm the list aka illustrator up word kid
book series and like you know dragons
yeah was he saying no word he was
talking about yeah I got some good stuff
that you know I'm going back and forth
with Dakota Meyer so he's gonna be
designing some of those yes so we have
some of that later kid posters canvases
wall hanging stuff from Mikey and the
Dragons you Mike in the Dragons artwork
let's face it
this doesn't look G it you know you you
consider yourself kind of an artist
right yes I do yes you do no doubt about
Pete Roberts are just over there
creating color palettes yes you are I
see you over there
yeah a little palette anyway your point
sir your my point is that we have to
admit that Mike and the Dragons artwork
is awesome well we're taking it we're
putting on two
legit sized canvases and you can hang it
up in your kid's room so your kid learns
to overcome his or her fear check agree
also on it so on it calm slash Jocko so
this is where you can get any kind of
fit like additional fitness gear awesome
fitness gear including kettlebells which
I recommend battle ropes maces clubs so
I've been talking to some of the guys
there he was telling me about the mace
or a club in both right yes this one is
the one with the longer is mace okay yes
Club is shortened yes the mace so I was
like yeah no I don't I don't really do
that workout but I looked into it and
that one might be beneficial the mace is
that even one official yeah
the well the mace and they're both
beneficial the thing that's beneficial
about them they're awkward yes they're
hard to handle yeah you know but I've
been doing like a lot of kettlebells
like heavier for as many reps it you
know it's like that kind you know
there's different you know you can do
like kettlebell for longest anyway the
more awkward kind of the thing and
you've been doing those sandbags to him
yeah I was yeah man those awkward thing
here's a good exercise with the sandbag
you just take your sandbag just heave it
over your head turn around heave it over
your head around heave it over your head
that's actually tiring oh and you're
gonna find that to be more tiring than
you expect especially because the first
one you're like oh gee aqua said this
was gonna be tiring it's not then you do
the number three and you're like Jacques
was not right number five you're like
why am i breathing hard and then you do
it like seven times you're like why
might been doing this yeah it's too
painful yes that's my experience
nonetheless okay I've been doing it and
consistently kind of for the first time
in life or a be like wait I try the work
cut school for a week or two and say get
school work out it's a good workout I
get it but I've been doing them for like
long time now kettlebells like these
awkwardly and in jiu-jitsu I feel this
it's not weird it's weird because it's
new so it's this new like lack of
tiredness you know how there's like
different tiredness is in jiu-jitsu
where you like okay I'm enrolling with
you know various people you know yeah
not you you Nisa I get it
and you know when you come back we can
roll or whatever and maybe I can really
put mine on tiredness to the test by
this like I'm saying you get few
different types of tiredness you're
looking really breathing eskimo that has
nine like 150 different names for snow
you know different styles of tired
negative no because there's Oh think
about it there's the pent airiness where
your breathing or hard but you know you
can still generate kind of force with
your muscles you know your muscles
aren't like noodley and oh yeah so
you're like you're not a muscle failure
yes which is he different it's different
and they already call that type of tired
muscle failing lots of fatigue eskimo
words for all these different things all
your different forms of fatigue anyway
or you can be like dang I'm not
breathing hard but I just I'm just so
weak my back I'm trained with me you
know that how much of you train with me
I don't know infinity times what what
how do you describe my tired all right
here's the I'm trying to think have you
ever seen me get tired I have with me no
no I've been tired I'll tell you that
there's a there's a couple times I
totally remember getting tired I was we
did he know ghee holiday training here
one time we started with no ghee we went
to ghee we had six I think it was six 10
minute rounds no it was six six minute
rounds nogi six six minute rounds ghee I
was tired at the end of that everyone
seola everyone does the leg I'll take a
rest round and then I'm gonna go get
choco by nonetheless I did it after
doing all these workouts
I don't feel the like body tired you
know like a dog don't feel it it's like
not even nearly as well like I really
got to get pushed to feel a bit so
anyway anyway the point is yeah go to on
it calms last chocolate look at all the
cool stuff on there grab something from
there that I don't really help you I'll
keep you in the game big-time books
choco
what do we got I've got a bunch of books
will the where there's a will that's the
latest way the warrior kid book where
there's a will getting some really good
reviews from people don't have you
finished it yet no oh you're still
working through it huh
anyways if you
to help your kids or any kids that you
know get on the path these are these are
books that everyone tells me and I will
tell you I wish I had these books when I
was 7 years old 8 years old 9 years old
10 years old 100% way the warrior kid
marks mission and where there's a will
check them out they're in multiple
different languages to check that out if
you speak a different language or your
children speak a different language you
can get that I also got Mikey and the
Dragons miking the Dragons is the book
that should be read to every kid at
least once a day from the ages of one
until six okay I just read it in a first
grade class you went in other words your
fresh cream sauce and read it
how'd that happen I went in there I got
nuts I told all the kids because I know
it's like they're trying to did their
goal of a teachers to keep the kids calm
right I come in there no that's not
happening so I'm like good morning
children
and like they're like good morning and
I'm like what good morning what I can't
hear you what I'm not sure what you're
saying can you please be louder so
they're amped and as I was getting them
all amped up I started getting nervous
because said wait a second I'm getting
these kids completely just jacked up and
getting crazy and hyper yeah and then
I'm gonna expect them to sit and listen
to me read this book which is a 15 maybe
an 18 minute read it's not it's not
short it's not short and so I was I was
like oh I might have overstepped my
balance I might add I'm gonna made up
long the tactical call so then I crack
open the book and this after you know
answer a couple questions I crack open
the book I read it boom silence and
total attention first 18 minutes while I
read the book so that book and I was to
explaining to the kids that I put I put
words and I said listen there's words in
this books that keep when you read them
people are saying time that that words
too big of a word for a little kid I
said these people want to make you
stupid I want to make you smart when you
see this word and I opened up poised
there's a thing right we use the word
poised yeah I rhyme it with noise and I
said these people don't want you
know what the word boys this and I read
it to him again that little section as
if we think that means and you know some
little kid little little Billy up front
is it mean like he said something really
smart he says does it mean you keep your
feelings inside and I said yes Billy
that's what it means don't let the man
keep you down they want to I want to
give you the dumbest book you can read
his books got a couple words you're
gonna you're gonna have to you have to
try and figure out what they mean but
you will poise you just figured it out
Billy you set an example for everyone in
this room yeah salute dancing William I
know yeah that's it man so that's Mike
in the dragons get that for the library
this is what you did there
whatever was my theory hypothesis you
know okay so your your I made you train
a little next belt level up yeah we okay
we're gonna say no sorry if with with
the kids when you're getting them all
fired up here's what you did you didn't
necessarily get them you there's a
difference between being loud and fired
up and being at attention so you got
like the the trouble from what I
understand that teachers and babysitters
away if you're looking after the bigger
and coaches and stuff like that's
looking after a big group of kids is
they don't they're they don't you don't
have their attention
yeah or fired up and a lot of the time
with kids they're so fired up that they
can't give you their attention so what
you did is you just basically wrangled
like a big horse wrangler wrangled all
of that fired up in this that these kids
actually had anyway but you got their
attention so maybe you didn't have to
like go against the grain with them at
all all you did was sort of funnel it
funnel it towards you so all that fire
done was towards you so when it was time
they'll do anything you say now yeah you
told me you actually you've actually
seen weed is this your first hand and
the effects lasted like weeks is weird
I'm going to show you both videos cuz I
said yeah that's right yeah okay so I'm
gonna tell the people if I haven't
already I don't know I'm gonna set in
thinking of okay so we're Dave Burke's
house good deal if good deal Burke's
house exactly right and we're leaving
it's time to leave so it's like my kids
my two
kids your kids were not there one of my
kids youngest yes your younger youngest
was there Dave Burke's kids Jamie and
Flynn Cochran's kids and well twos
anymore it was a lot this is a lot of
candidates yes and jock was there so you
did these actually did the exact same
thing with them as you did with the kids
in the class yes which is good by the
way so you're going attached I like it
you don't catch you're giving your
assessment and I have the video to
revisit - I have one and my wife has one
so my wife's one she's videoing you and
your it cutscene where you're going like
this you're going go go go with your
hands side to side and the kids are
trying to keep up they're like Oh what
are we doing okay and slowly they start
doing you're like and then you start
yelling at them yes you're not doing it
loud enough yeah the same thing huka
huka and they all start doing they fall
in light they're doing it louder or
whatever in your like louder of course
they want to be louder huh so they kids
so they can and they fall in light and
they do it you're like good and then you
give them high-fives right good job give
one half I'm your like harder you've won
hi fight just to whichever random kid so
you say harder then they hit you with
the harder high-five then you go ah real
loud and you mean of course that gets
everyone else fired up like they want to
do the same thing so you're like going
from kid to kid highfive saying ah I
mean it I was trying to do it harder
than the last kid or whatever meanwhile
when other kids if you notice when other
kids are giving you high-five the ones
that are not giving you high fives are
just watching full attention just
waiting waiting for the next thing
now the point of this story that made
significant to me was because - not even
two weeks I let me be like a week later
right my son who's - my daughter who's
six my daughter accidentally and my wife
has this on video - because they're
playing and doing little dances or
whatever on accident my daughter steps
on my son's wrist just on accident when
their pennant you know in the in the
Scramble so my son gets up he's like
Eagles ah and hits my daughter right and
goes mean what the heck that's kind of
weird you know that was a weird
outbursts
Oh Michael and then but my wife Clara
she kind of remembered something about
it right so she revisits the video that
she took of you going I mean so it was
like a hit and then a point ah yeah
right that's what you did they hit in
your version was a high-five sure enough
I see my son's little head watching the
whole time just in the corner he didn't
do any ice he was watching the whole
thing go revisit my son daughters
virgins same exact thing boom incident
right steps on the wrist instead of
high-five he does a hit to her shoulder
or whatever in a high-five fashion it
goes mean the exact same tone is you
your children are always learning yes so
if you want your children to learn
properly the right stuff read them like
game the dragons yeah but see what you
did there with the attention right
hailing it's it's totally effective
that's a good note man I mean that's a
good little Dannic technique I'm gonna
use it you know I'm gonna use it
Jack don't do it before a bit time don't
forget about the discipline equals
freedom Field Manual this is the
graduation gift right get it for your
kids what are they 15 17 19 22 24
getting done with their masters get them
to discipline equals freedom field medal
they got work to do
we all do if you want it on audio it's
on iTunes it's on Amazon music Google
Play and all that then you got extreme
ownership and the dichotomy leadership
written both by me and my brother Leif
Babbitt they are books about leadership
and they will give you some principles
that you can apply to every single
situation you are in in business in life
dichotomy leadership and extreme
ownership speaking of life we have a
leadership consultancy and what we do is
solve problems inside organizations and
we solve them through leadership because
that's where the problem is
so it's me it's late fab and JP Danelle
Dave Burke Flynn Cochran Mike Cirelli
Mike bimah and Jason Gardner if you need
help in your organization with
leadership go - alone front calm and
also we have EF online
because leadership training is not an
inoculation it's just like jiu-jitsu you
can't just show up one day now you know
jiu-jitsu you can't just show up read
one book and or go to one seminar and
now you're a good leader no you have to
continually train and that's what EF
online is interactive leadership
training new modules coming out monthly
it's got me and the rest of the echelon
from team working with you to give you
pragmatic skills go to EF online for
that also the muster Chicago done it was
sold out
next up Denver it's gonna sell out
Sydney Australia December 4th and 5th
the Denver one is September 19th and
20th go to extreme ownership calm if you
want to come to these events because
they are going to sell out so go there
early and EF overwatch where when you're
looking to hire someone don't think oh I
got to find the person that has the
specific skills that I want no what you
want is to hire the right person with
the right kind of character and the most
important skill that they can have is
leadership skills and then you can teach
them the technical skills that they need
to know for the job
we have people with character and with
leadership capability from Special
Operations in combat aviation and we can
put them into your organization it's our
company EF overwatch its EF overwatch
comm if you need leadership in your
business or team and if you want to hear
more from myself and echo Charles we're
on the interwebs or on Twitter
we're on Instagram and we are on
Echo's Antico Charlson I am at Jocko
willing and once again thanks to all the
veterans out there men like John Stryker
Meyer who fought for the American ideal
and who himself represents that ideal
true American Hero humbled to sit here
and talk to him and to those of you that
are out there on the front lines right
now thank you for fighting for our
ideals as well and also thanks to police
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
EMTs dispatchers correctional officers
Border Patrol Secret Service first
responders thanks to you for living a
life of service and sacrifice so that we
can live our lives in safety and
security in to everyone else out there
remember John Stryker Myer is written
about and told us stories that he lived
through and some of them are just hard
to believe but also remember that for
every story of bravery and heroism that
he tells there are an infinite number of
stories that never got told stories from
the men who did not come home soldiers
sailors airmen and Marines who gave away
all their stories past present and
future they sacrificed all those stories
the stories of their lives for us
never forget them and until next time
this is echo and Jocko out